pogo
wobei das emote ist ja deaktiviert
geht ja gar nicht mehr
haben wir noch pogo
kurz emote
gibt es nicht mehr
deaktiviert
weil alle pog emotes entfernt wurden
subscribern
nice
oh ich höre gerade die subscription notification funktionieren wieder
danke schön für den sub
julie genetics
ja pogo
ist tatsächlich entfernt
rejected
von ffz
und von
guck mal wie es bei der
twitch tv aussieht wahrscheinlich auch
rejected
ne da können wir pogo wieder adden
so
ich interessiere mich überhaupt nicht
für irgendwelche politischen sachen um emotes
ich will einfach meine emotes haben
so nice
so funktioniert wieder alles
hey leute ich war ein bisschen
witzig
ich bin ja jetzt schon ein bisschen
on in letzter zeit
sowohl video technisch als auch
livestream technisch ich weiß
ich bin gerade sinnloserweise
old school mmo's grinden
weil es bock macht
so aber
ich hatte gestern schon vorhin ein video aufzunehmen
was zu d
mal wieder über das led schiebte das
da gibt es ein paar interessante neuigkeiten
microsoft hatte einen report rausgebracht
über
das letzte jahr was die in azure so für ddos attacken mit e
mitbekommen haben, beziehungsweise
vereiteln konnten. Ich meine, Microsoft
möchte natürlich Werbung für sich selbst machen.
Und
da waren richtig
riesen Dinger dabei.
Da wollte ich was drüber machen. Habe ich gestern
angefangen aufzunehmen, beziehungsweise ich habe angefangen
was aufzuschreiben, nicht angefangen aufzunehmen.
Habe ich angefangen was aufzuschreiben,
habe mich nebenbei MMO-technisch
eingeloggt und
habe gesehen, ach guck mal,
PVP, BG und so alles schon ab,
bin gejoint. Ich habe morgens um 10 Uhr angefangen,
bin gestern um 22 Uhr ins Bett. Ich habe 12
Stunden am Stück Kreisel
Grind gemacht. Weird Champ.
Ich habe das auch gemerkt, dass ich keine 22
mehr bin oder so. Mir hat richtig der
Arsch wehgetan am Abend
vom ganzen Sitzen.
Ich habe auch zum ersten Mal seit
langer Zeit mal wieder am Rechner
Mittag gegessen und Abend gegessen. Mache ich
ja normalerweise nicht mehr.
Moin.
Bist du eigentlich Twitch-Partner geworden?
Ich habe einen Antrag gestellt,
aufgenommen zu werden
in das Twitch-Partner.
Ich habe ein Partnerprogramm
und dann wurde ich Twitch-Partner.
Im Prinzip so wie jeder andere auch.
Der Umus sagt,
Max hatte ein Meeting am Freitag,
da hat ein angeblicher,
bei ihm ist man sich immer nicht sicher,
der jebaitet auch gerne mit seinen Chat-Messages.
Bevor ich jetzt weiterlese,
er hat schon öfters jebaitet, also das ist immer mit
Vorsicht zu genießen, was er so schreibt.
Max hatte ein Meeting am Freitag,
da hat ein angeblicher Dev gesagt,
das mit Laravel nutzen, sagt dir,
dass das nichts mir nicht, was?
Also entweder ist es früher oder heute.
Also Max hatte ein Meeting am Freitag.
Okay, da hat ihm ein angeblicher Entwickler gesagt,
das mit Laravel nutzen, sagt dir das,
das hat mir nichts gesagt.
Ach so, er wollte wissen, ob dir Laravel was sagt.
Würde gerne mal wissen, was du darüber darüber sagst.
Er hat so geredet, als ob der Laden das nächste S hat.
Ja, das ist ja noch.
Ja, das ist ja normal.
Also darüber zu reden, dass der nächste Laden,
das nächste Google, Microsoft, SAP, Netflix,
was auch immer, was auch immer so die Branche passt,
wird, ist ja normal. Das machen sie alle.
Ich glaube, ich war noch bei keinem Unternehmen,
was nicht intern die ganze Zeit erzählt hat,
dass sie absolut genial,
die besten und eigentlich das krasseste Unternehmen
auf der Welt sind.
Das ist, glaube ich, Standard.
Ja, kannst, ja, poste ruhig.
Ist okay.
Das ist normal.
Und wir können uns gleich angucken.
Ja, also wie gesagt, das ist normal.
Ob man Laravel jetzt kennen muss, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich kenne es.
Das ist ein PHP Framework.
Ja, ich habe damit mal, falls ich noch irgendjemand hat.
Zufälligerweise mal jemand auf meinem damaligen Battlefield 4 Server gespielt.
Dort gab es eine Stats Page.
Weil EA sowas nicht anbietet, angeboten hat.
Und ich habe eine Stats Page für meinen Battlefield 4 Server damals gemacht.
Wo jeder so ein eigenes Profil haben konnte mit seinem Spielernamen.
Das war mit Laravel.
Aber das war Laravel 0.5 oder sowas.
Das ist uralt.
Ja, aber wie gesagt,
also ich finde, man kann das durchaus gehört haben.
Großartig Ahnung davon haben, weiß ich nicht.
PHP ist jetzt ja mittlerweile nicht mehr so,
dass so das Must Have, Must Know,
Ding schlechthin, also man das unbedingt kennen muss, weiß ich nicht, eher nicht.
Ich meine, breite Übersicht haben und schon alles mal ein bisschen gehört haben, ist immer gut.
Aber jetzt, also das wäre jetzt für mich jetzt kein Kriterium gewesen,
dich zu nehmen oder nicht zu nehmen, wenn du davon noch nichts gehört hast.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, der Laden setzt ausschließlich Laravel ein und wollen jemand,
der da auf hohem Niveau schon direkt einsteigen kann.
Dann ist es natürlich, dass man sich nicht mehr so einig ist.
Dann ist es natürlich blöd, jemanden einzustellen,
der von dem eigentlichen Framework, worauf der ganze Laden basiert, noch nichts gehört hat.
Aber ansonsten dieses Gelaber,
dass der Laden das nächste SAP, Google, Microsoft, Netflix,
Meta ist es ja, was auch immer,
und Google ist es ja auch nicht,
weil es ist ja eigentlich jetzt Alphabet und ihr wisst, was ich meine,
ist, das ist normal.
Und das finde ich genauso lächerlich wie du,
dass die alle immer so übertrieben Selbstansicht haben.
Ja.
Die 0815-Ecke, äh, Klitsch,
um die Ecke ist halt nicht das nächste Netflix oder das nächste Microsoft.
Und wird es wahrscheinlich auch nie werden.
Ja.
Na ja, witzig, witzig finde ich es dann immer,
wenn die, wenn die Stellenanzeigen haben oder der Meinung sind,
irgendwelche krassen, äh, so Brainteaser-Tests und alles mögliche machen zu müssen,
das kann vielleicht Microsoft und Google machen, ne?
Die, die wollen ja auch wirklich die Besten und die Besten wollen zu ihnen.
Aber aus 69 Zuschauern,
äh, huge, Gachi-Buzz.
Aber ist bei denen ja gar nicht der Fall.
So.
Du hast hier die Seite von denen angeschaut, das ist WordPress,
ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Halbe Million für ein Projekt ist ja gar nichts.
500.000 Euro Budget für je nachdem, ist gar nichts.
Du musst dir mal überlegen,
allein schon, wenn du ein Team hast mit 10 Entwicklern,
können die für eine halbe Million ein halbes Jahr,
ein halbes Jahr bis Jahr,
daran arbeiten, dann ist das Geld weg.
Also, Budget, Budget von einer halben Million ist ja gar nichts
für ein etwas umfangreicheres IT-Projekt.
Also, je nachdem, in welchen Sphären die da schweben.
Also, wenn sie das nächste SAP sein wollen, auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht.
So, okay, Leute.
Also, was gibt's denn sonst Neues?
Ich versuche nachher das Video fertig aufzunehmen zu der ganzen DDoS-Thematik.
Wer das nicht gesehen hat, ich zeige, versuche ich, ich zeige euch das grad mal.
Ähm.
Ich hab's hier gar nicht.
Ich glaube, Heiser hat einen News-Post dazu gemacht.
DDoS.
Nicht Doos, DDoS.
Ja.
Und dann gibt's einen Original-News-Artikel von Microsoft, genau.
Da waren echt ein paar interessante Sachen drinne und zum Beispiel wusstet ihr,
dass das Internet in Andorra lag.
Hat das jemand von euch mitgekriegt?
Das muss ich mal...
Internet Andorra.
Wusstet ihr, dass das Internet in Andorra weg war,
weil irgendein Minecraft-Turnier gedDoS-t wurde?
Das war mir neu.
War mir neu bis gestern.
Hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ja.
Die ganze Minecraft-Zoom war wieder hier am Start.
Wusstet ihr was ich... hab ich mir nicht genauer angeguckt.
Warum?
Keine Ahnung.
Durch DDoS-Angriffe auf einen Internet-Provider in Andorra wurden mehrere Minecraft-Tournees,
die in Andorra geöffnet wurden, geöffnet worden.
ips geöffnet worden, geöffnet worden.
Und mit Andorra wurden mehrere Minecraft-Spieler aus einem Turnier gekegelt.
Ahja, ok.
Die wollten irgendwelche Leutes, die am Turnier teilgenommen haben, nicht, dass sie am Turnier
teilnehmen und haben sie gedDoS.
Und das hat den Serviceprovider in Andorra lahmgelegt und damit dementsprechend wohl
auch komplette Internetsachen in Andorra.
So bescheuert.
Vermutet wir, dass der Angreifer den einzigen Serviceprovider bland attackiert...
Ääääh.
Gut, das ist Andorra.
Wie viel Einwohner hat Andorra?
450.
450. Okay,
77.000. Ich hab nichts gesagt.
Aber, ja.
Die Richtung
stimmte nicht.
Ja.
Das ist so bescheuert.
Tja, da hat's
dann auch die Oma in Andorra abgekriegt,
die mal kurz im Internet irgendwie
mit ihrem Enkel chatten wollte oder so.
Weil irgendwelche Leute
Minecraft-Sachen gededost haben.
Schon heftig. Zumindest ist es
interessant, was in diesem Microsoft-DDoS-Report
drinne steht. Also das Erste, was ich
bemerkenswert fand,
wo ich nicht mit gerechnet habe,
dass sich DDoS-Angriffe
mittlerweile hauptsächlich
gegen Games richten.
Also zumindest da, wo es
am meisten Angriffe gab und am härtesten
waren tatsächlich Games.
Also geht an von Blizzard-Spielen, Titanfall
haben wir alle mitgekriegt, Tarkov, Dead by Daylight,
Final Fantasy XIV wurde auch gededost.
Ja, irgendwelche
VPN-Voypals,
Zipdings-Anbieter und sonst was.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz interessant.
Das zu lesen
ist nicht so spannend, aber so ein paar Punkte
da draußen, deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache da auch mal
ein Video drüber.
Natürlich ist dieser ganze Artikel Werbung von Microsoft
unterm Strich, weil
es geht darum, dass Microsoft
so geil ist und mit ihrer Azure DDoS
Protection die Welt rettet.
Was auch sonst.
Was anderes hätten wir
glaube ich jetzt von Microsoft
nicht erwartet.
Zum Glück stand im Artikel noch mal drin, dass es zwischen
Frankreich und Spanien liegt.
Ja, das liegt in den Pyrenäen irgendwo, glaube ich, ne?
Andorra, so auf dem Berg oben drauf.
Ich wohne ja in Andorra, also laut, laut Twitter.
Andorra, gucken wir mal.
Maps, ja.
Ach da.
Hier, hier.
Hat das nicht mal Smoother gescrollt?
Google Maps, das ist ja eklig.
Warum ist es so eklig?
Warum scrollt Google Maps so beschissen?
Was ist hier los?
Liegt es daran, dass es...
dass die erkennen, dass ich nicht im Chrome bin, oder was?
Hä?
Leute, seit wann...
Guck mal, hier scrollt
Smooth bei mir nicht.
She baited.
Die wollen mal wieder
Browser ausschließen, hier.
Anzeige ist raus.
Und ich kann euch noch mal was zeigen.
Passt mal auf.
Das ist richtig krass auf YouTube.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mit denen abgeht.
Hier, Kanalmitglied.
Ach so, super.
Hier, guckt mal.
Ich zoome mal kurz ran.
Guckt euch mal.
Ja, müssen wir so mal...
Ne, hier sehen die Emotes auch kacke aus.
Woran liegt das denn?
Hä?
Bei mir skalieren die Emotes im Firefox nicht richtig,
aber im Chrome schon.
Und hier skalieren sie auch nicht richtig.
Hä?
Verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Hier ist es umgedreht.
Hier skalieren die Emotes im Firefox richtig und im Chrome nicht.
Was ist denn mit Google kaputt?
Guck mal.
Also bei mir ist es normalerweise immer umgedreht.
Die Emotes skalieren im Chrome richtig, aber im Firefox nicht.
Und hier skalieren sie richtig im Firefox, aber im Chrome...
Was?
Warum?
Ihr seht, die Emotes sind deutlich schärfer als da.
Okay, die Logik muss ich nicht verstehen, oder?
Aber es ist schon mal merkwürdig,
warum skalieren die Emotes überhaupt unter die Chrome?
Warum skalieren die Emotes unter die Chrome?
Warum skalieren die Emotes unterschiedlich in den Browsern?
Warum sind die nicht einfach überall scharf?
Nein, so schwer ist es jetzt ja auch nicht,
das ordentlich zu machen, ne?
Also, keine Ahnung.
Naja.
Ach ja.
Leute, ist sonst irgendwas Spannendes passiert die Woche?
Ist sonst irgendwas Spannendes passiert?
Nee, oder?
33 hochsensible Mails verkauft.
Kommt immer mal wieder vor.
Krass, schon um 9 ziehen mir seit gestern Abend das 24er Date...
Date...
Okay.
Ja, wem's gefällt.
So, Autorennen und, und...
Wie nennt man diese Kategorie?
Auto, Sport, Motor...
Motorsport, nicht Autosport.
Motorsport.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ja, es muss CSS-Magic sein, die kaputt ist.
Übrigens, zum Thema CSS-Magic.
Ich will's jetzt nicht...
Ich will's jetzt nicht zu weit ausweiten,
weil das hier im Stream
die Leute sonst zu sehr verschreckt.
Ich will's jetzt nicht zu weit ausweiten, weil das hier im Stream
Ihr könnt euch doch noch dran erinnern
an das Autocomplete-Form, was wir letzten Samstag
oder so programmiert haben.
Ich hab ne Idee, wie wir die Abfragen noch viel, viel schneller machen können.
Das müssen wir demnächst ausprobieren.
Meine SQL-Abfragen
waren nämlich ziemlich
low IQ.
Die waren nicht gut gemacht.
Wenn ich die sinnvoller mache,
dann sollten wir noch deutlich schneller abfragen
als irgendwie 40 Millisekunden.
Da sollten wir runter auf unter 10 Millisekunden kommen.
Linus Sechtips hat Datenverlust.
Hat er wirklich oder ist das wieder so?
Das ist wieder so ein G-Bait-Video.
Der ist mir nämlich immer ein bisschen zu entspannt
in seinen Hilfe.
Wir haben einen unternehmensbedrohenden
Datenverlust-Videos.
Der hat ja schon ein paar Videos dieser Art gehabt.
Und der erscheint mir immer
ein wenig zu entspannt dafür,
als dass es doch so schlimm ist,
wie sie es im Video darstellen.
Du meinst das da?
Naja.
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir das gucken.
Aber ich sollte mir irgendjemand geschrieben,
ich sollte mir diesen Clip angucken.
Die Mario-Karten-Musik dabei laufen.
Angel, das hätte ich gern.
Wolle, danke für den Sub.
Lass mich raten, er stirbt jetzt sinnlos.
Achso, das ist der Sonnenuntergang,
der ist in der falschen Richtung, oder was?
Achso.
Okay, da wäre ich jetzt ohne,
ich habe den ja nicht zuhört, gar nicht drauf gekommen.
Wobei, ist es nicht abhängig davon,
wo auf der Welt man ist?
Ist es nicht sogar ein bisschen davon abhängig,
Also, bei uns ist es im Westen, glaube.
Irgendwo im Westen.
Aber ist es nicht ein bisschen davon abhängig?
Achso.
Excellent, Firefight-Content.
Ja, aber ich glaube, es variiert trotzdem ein bisschen.
Also, es ist immer die gleiche Richtung,
aber es ist, glaube ich, ein Unterschied,
ob es, keine Ahnung, dann
irgendwie
westlich ist, nordwestlich
oder südwestlich oder sonst wie.
Ich glaube,
das hängt schon ein bisschen davon ab,
wo die Erde ist.
Ja, die Himmelsrichtungen mögen überall gleich sein,
aber der Sonnenaufgang kann ja bei den einen
direkt, direkt hardcore westlich sein,
bei den anderen ein bisschen nordwestlich.
Die Erde ist ja auch leicht schräg.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das ist unterschiedlich,
je nachdem, wo man auf der Erde ist.
Wenn man jetzt natürlich auf einer flachen Erde wäre,
dann wäre das wieder was anderes.
Da habe ich auch letztens wieder ein Video gesehen,
da habe ich den Glauben an die Menschheit verloren.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Die sind teilweise so absolut
gehirnbefreit, die Leute.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Wir kommen jetzt, wir fragen einfach Kugel.
Sonnenuntergang
Richtung.
Die tägliche
Veränderung des Sonnenstandes wird durch
...
Zwischen Nordwest
und Südwest. Seht ihr, Leute, das kann sich
unterscheiden.
Vielleicht unterscheidet sich das auch nach Jahreszeiten,
keine Ahnung. Wo geht die Sonne auf?
Was? Wo geht die Sonne
auf, Deutschland?
Was?
Fehlt da nicht noch ein Wort?
Die mögliche Richtung variiert also fast um 90 Grad.
Okay, siehste, Wikipedia weiß Bescheid.
Aha, aha.
Pfeifert-Content wieder.
Es hängt nicht auf der Position auf der Erde,
sondern von der Jahreszeit ab,
sowie der geografischen Breite.
Doch, ist doch davon, ist doch wichtig, wo man auf der Erde ist.
Wo der Untergang am Horizont beginnt,
hängt von der Jahreszeit zu
der geografischen Breite ab.
Aha.
Zur Tag- und Nachtgleiche
ist er auf allen Breiten fast genau im Westen.
Es ändert sich also der Punkt, wo es anfängt.
Im Dezember, Januar ging es für Mittelalter im Südwesten
und im Juni, Juli Nordwest.
Das ändert sich.
Exzellent.
Chat, jetzt wissen wir wieder Bescheid.
Alles klar.
Gibt's auch schöne Videos zu Skipper, zu fast allen Videos.
Was gucken wir uns heute als erstes an?
Ich würde es, ach so, ja, ich sollte mir das, das,
our data ist, der Typ ist mir immer viel, wie gesagt,
er ist mir viel zu entspannt dafür,
dass ihre Daten weg sind.
Und es ist auch eines der Gründe,
warum ich die letzten Jahre über eigentlich kaum noch gucke.
Also es gibt zwei Arten von Videos, die ich nicht mag.
Das eine ist so Videos aus der Mücke in den Elefanten gemacht,
was sie auch teilweise gerne hier haben.
Oder halt Sachen, die, die, ich will nicht sagen gestellt,
aber überdramatisiert sind.
Aber gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal.
When I say we store and handle a lot of data for a YouTube channel,
I mean it.
I mean, we built some sick 100 plus terabyte servers
for some of our fellow YouTubers,
but those are nothing compared to...
Warum?
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht verstehe?
Also wenn, jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft,
wenn quasi meine Existenz des Unternehmens
an einem File-Server hängt,
so wie das ja immer dargestellt wird in diesen Videos,
sollte ich da nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise
insofern Vorkehrungen treffen,
dass mich der Ausfall dieses File-Servers
nicht mein ganzes Geld kostet?
Wäre das nicht sinnvoll irgendwie?
Also zum Beispiel würde ich mir dreimal überlegen,
ob ich einen eigenen File-Server zusammenbaue,
wenn mein Unternehmen davon abhängt.
Da würde ich mir zum Beispiel überlegen,
ob ich mir nicht ein fertiges Storage-System kaufe,
was dann an irgendeiner Kiste angebunden wird,
wo ich Samba drüber machen kann oder Windows Chairs,
oder aber die bisschen besseren Storage-Systeme
können ja mittlerweile alle schon selbst...
Gucken wir mal.
Ach, heutzutage messen wir was in Warzone-Installationen, top!
Lautstärke ziemlich...
Das ist einfach...
Also wenn das wirklich so ist,
dann ist das einfach Unfähigkeit.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn die eigene Existenz
an den Daten auf diesem File-Server hängt,
dann müsste schon echt der gesamte Kontinent quasi
instant gleichzeitig abfackeln,
dass ich da irgendwelche Daten verlieren würde.
Also wenn man es ordentlich macht, ja?
Das wird dann nicht nur lokal gebackupt,
das wird ordentlich gebackupt,
das wird Offside-Backup
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur einmal.
Also wirklich Verlust
sollte da eigentlich nahezu ausgeschlossen sein.
Was passieren kann, ist, dass der Service
vielleicht mal einen halben Tag oder so
nicht zur Verfügung steht.
Wenn man das natürlich einfach nur
auf irgendwelche lokal zusammengeschusterten Platten schiebt
und sich dann wundert, dass es kaputt geht...
Der Werbung ist hetzener Werbung,
ja gut, der weiß halt, was gut ist, ne?
Ja, egal.
Wir haben keine Backup für.
Wir wissen noch nicht, wie viel,
aber was wir wissen, ist, was falsch war
und wir haben einen Plan, was wir schaffen können.
Aber es wird ein bisschen Arbeit nehmen.
Und ein bisschen Geld.
Dank unserem Sponsor hetzener.
hetzener bietet hochwertige Cloud-Server
für einen tollen Preis.
Mit ihrer neuen US-Lokation in Ashburn, Virginia...
Leute, hat jemand schon ausprobiert,
ob Ausrufezeichen hetzener, ob mein Gutscheincode noch funktioniert?
In letzter Zeit?
... in vier verschiedenen Lokationen
können Sie sich von Features wie
Loadbalancers, Block-Storage und mehr bieten.
Benutzt den Code LTT22
auf der Link unten für 20 Dollar.
Der Raid bringt dir nicht zwangsläufig was.
Ah, da macht dich so ein Krach.
Lass uns mit ein bisschen Hintergrund auf unseren Servern beginnen.
Unsere Archival-Storage besteht aus
zwei diskreten GlusterFS-Klustern.
Beide werden über zwei 45-Driven
Storinator-Server verbreitet,
alle mit 60 Harddriven.
Das ursprüngliche Petabyte-Projekt
besteht aus den Delta-1 und Delta-2
Servern
und wird mit dem Moniker
Old Vault genannt.
Petabyte-Projekt 2,
oder der neue Vault,
ist Delta-3 und Delta-4.
Nun, wegen der Natur unserer Inhalte...
Also, Raid ist eine gute Sache,
wenn du willst, dass das Service bestehen bleibt.
Ähm...
Also, wenn du... also...
Raid ist gut dafür, wenn du willst, dass du
bei einem Ausfall nicht den...
dass deine Leute noch weiterarbeiten können,
wenn eine Platte kaputt geht.
So, ähm...
Das Dumme an Raid ist,
dass es, sagen wir mal,
so halbwegs synchron ist.
Also sprich, wenn du aus Versehen
was löschst auf dem einen...
Also, wenn du... wenn du...
wenn du auf den Windows-Share gehst
und jetzt, ähm, Entfernen drückst
und löschst, dann ist es halt weg.
Oder wenn du Malware hast,
die dein NAS verschlüsselt,
das ist dem Raid halt egal.
Dann könntest du, was weiß ich,
wenn du Glück hast, hast du vielleicht
irgendwie irgendwelche ZFS-Snapshots
oder sowas, dass du schnell wieder rückgängig machst.
Ja.
Und wenn der Server nicht läuft,
dann, äh, ja...
Also, Raid bringt schon was.
Hat schon so einen Sinn.
Was, Raid 5, 6, 10 funktioniert seit 2000?
Warum sollte das seit 2014 nicht mehr funktionieren?
Was hat sich denn an der grundlegenden Logik
von Raid geändert,
was seit 2014 nicht mehr funktionieren soll?
Natürlich funktioniert Raid 5 und 6 2014 immer noch.
Kannst 6 Platten nehmen oder 5 Platten
oder was auch immer und Raid 6 machen.
Das ist kein Ding.
Warum sollte das nicht mehr funktionieren?
Und Raid 10 ist ja eigentlich
nur eine Zusammenfassung aus zwei Raid-Level.
Funktioniert immer noch.
Unter Windows?
Keine Ahnung, aber...
Bei Linux gibt's da verschiedene Varianten.
Du kannst mit ZFS machen,
du kannst mit, ähm, MD-Raid machen,
du kannst, glaub ich, sogar...
Ich glaub sogar, dass, ähm,
LVM mittlerweile eine, äh,
eine Mirror-Geschichte eingebaut hat.
Naja, gucken wir mal weiter.
in a tech wizard category so we've always had
it's substantially lower need for tech support
than the average company.
And as a result
we have never hired a full time IT person.
Despite the handful of times,
perhaps including this one,
that it probably would have been helpful.
So in the early days I managed the Infrastructure
and since then I've had some help
from both outside sources
and other members of the writing team .
Das ist übrigens auch ein Grund, warum gerade im Banken-Business-Umfeld, da wo ich arbeite,
warum sie total auf SLAs und irgendwelche Support-Verträge stehen.
Nicht, weil es dadurch weniger kaputt geht, sondern weil sie im Fall der Fälle, wenn was kaputt geht,
quasi den schwarzen Peter jemand anderem zuschieben können.
Die können einfach sagen so, ja, das Storage-System ist kaputt gegangen,
aber eigentlich haben wir hier Verfügbarkeit 99,99999999 eingekauft und es ist trotzdem kaputt gegangen.
Wir sind nicht schuld, der Storage-Hersteller ist schuld.
Es ist erstaunlich, wie oft.
Wie oft das zieht.
Letztendlich müsste man eigentlich sagen, ja gut, aber du hast den doch ausgesucht,
du bist trotzdem verantwortlich, macht man aber anscheinend nicht.
Und deswegen sind SLAs und Business-Sachen total beliebt.
Natürlich geht es dann auch letztendlich darum, dass du Schadensersatz fordern kannst und sonst was.
Aber ich muss euch mal ehrlich sagen, zumindest in dem Umfeld, also bei der Bank, wo ich arbeite,
ich habe natürlich mit der Rechtsabteilung jetzt auch nicht tagtäglich was zu tun, also keine Ahnung,
mir ist nicht bekannt.
Und dass wir jemals erfolgreich Schadensersatz bekommen haben, wenn einer was kaputt gemacht hat
oder wenn einer SLAs nicht richtig eingehalten hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es nie versucht haben oder ob wir nie gewonnen haben.
Keine Ahnung, aber wir haben nie, also nie, dass ich mitbekommen habe, was rausgekriegt.
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, wenn man nur irgendwelche Turnschuh-Admin-Bastler hat.
Das ist schön und gut, ich spreche denen nicht das Know-how oder den Skill oder sonst was ab,
aber manchmal ist es tatsächlich gut, wenn man jemanden hat, der in einem gewissen Bereich schon Erfahrung hat,
auch schon gesehen hat, was ist, wenn es in die Hose geht und einfach weiß, was er macht.
Und kein Bastler für alles ist.
...before we get into the rest of this.
Nothing that happened is the result of anything other than us messing up.
Gucken wir mal.
The hardware, both from 45Drives and from Seagate,
who provided the bulk of what makes up our...
Ah, das sind Einwolf-Platten, habe ich auch.
...and we would recommend checking out both of them.
If you or your business has serious data storage needs,
we're gonna have links to them down below.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn mein Business serious data storage needs hatte,
würde ich tatsächlich...
...wahrscheinlich mir...
...irgendein fertiges Storage-System kaufen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen teurer,
aber es ist halt die Frage, mit was bezahlst du es, ja?
...the best hardware in the world...
...bezahlst du es vor oder nachher?
...would be shut down by misconfigured software.
And Jake, who tasked himself with auditing our current infrastructure,
found just such a thing.
Everything was actually going pretty well.
He was setting up monitoring and alerts,
verifying that every machine would gracefully shut down when the power goes out,
which happens a lot here for some reason,
but he eventually worked his way around to the Petabyte-Project-Servers
and checked the status of the ZFS-Pools...
Ja, ja, gerade für so Kram wie ESX, da brauchst du das ja auch,
da kannst du ja selbst nicht wirklich großartig was machen,
geschweige denn da irgendwie durchblicken, ja, ja.
Für ESX...
Was wir beispielsweise auch regelmäßig benutzen,
möglicherweise habe ich gerade den Tab offen, ja,
ist der Oracle-Support, wobei man sagen muss, der Oracle-Support, der ist...
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Typ da hinten?
Was will der mir sagen? Will mir irgendwas verkaufen?
Ähm, der Oracle-Support ist nur mäßig...
Der Oracle-Support ist nur mäßig nützlich,
genauso wie der Microsoft-Support.
Also der Oracle...
Leute, eine Support-Anfrage bei Oracle und Microsoft
läuft in der Regel gleich ab.
Du machst dann ein Ticket auf, ich muss es zum Glück nie machen,
ja, aber ich krieg das mit, wenn unser Support
oder irgendwelche Leute Tickets aufmachen,
du machst bei Oracle oder Microsoft machst du ein Support-Ticket auf,
da schreibst du dann zum Beispiel rein,
ähm, ich muss irgendein Beispiel, was nicht allzu fern ist,
von der Realität ausdenken,
ähm, NFS, zum Beispiel, ja,
zum Beispiel schreibst du
Azure-Files-NFS-Performance
ist, äh,
viel, viel, viel langsamer als
erwartet und auch langsamer als bei Ihnen
in den Dokumenten drinne steht.
So, ähm,
dann antwortet sofort
irgendeiner da drauf, auf dieses
Ticket. Warum,
Chat, warum antwortet immer instant
einer drauf, ohne dass es was Hilfreiches ist?
Also meistens bekommt man als erstes
so eine Antwort auf sein Ticket,
ähm, so nach dem Motto, bitte
Analyse-Tool laufen lassen,
oder, äh, bitte genau
Firmware-Versionen angeben,
oder es fehlen noch irgendwelche
Nummern oder sonst was in der Richtung,
ähm, also es gibt
immer instant eine Antwort drauf,
oder dass es weitergeleitet wird an
irgendwas. Warum ist das so? Das ist ganz einfach,
weil die bezahlt werden für
Reaktionszeiten. Die werden,
genau, die werden bezahlt für
Reaktionszeiten.
Bei so Reaktionszeiten geht's in der
Regel nicht der Realität
entsprechend darum, dass
etwas helfen wird sinnvoll, sondern einfach nur,
dass reagiert wird.
Auch eines meiner Kritikpunkte,
die ich generell an, an, an
vielen so Business-Dingern habe,
die sind oftmals nicht daran interessiert,
dass die eigentlichen Probleme
behoben werden, sondern
nur, dass irgendwelche messbaren
Dinger passieren,
die oftmals gar nicht zur Lösung
beitragen, ja, zum Beispiel Reaktionszeiten in Tickets.
Reaktionszeiten in Tickets ist nicht
wirklich aussagekräftig, wenn das eigentliche Problem
erst ein halbes Jahr später gelöst wird.
Gut, es antwortet bei Microsoft
immer instant irgendein Typ drauf, mit
irgendeinem Schwachsinn, den man nicht haben will.
Dann wird das weitergeleitet an was auch immer
irgendwie das jeweilige zuständige Team.
Und dann
kommt immer, und das ist wirklich,
ich sag mal 99% der Zeit,
schreibt jemand von Microsoft
oder von Oracle,
aber Microsoft, habe ich es erst
letztens vor ein paar Tagen wieder gesehen,
der schreibt das Problem,
was du hast, schreibt der
nochmal in eigenen Worten in das
Ticket rein. Also wenn du schreibst,
wir haben festgestellt,
dass NFS
Zugriff viel zu hohe Latenz
hat und langsam ist in das Ticket
und dann antwortet
er dir,
ihr Problem scheint es zu sein, dass der Zugriff
auf NFS langsam ist. Haben
sie sich schon einmal überlegt,
dass der Zugriff über
NFS vielleicht zu langsam sein könnte?
Sowas in der Richtung kommt da
als Antwort rein.
Und natürlich, das schreiben die dann
über irgendwie eine halbe Seite
lang, das ist immer richtig viel Text,
aber im Prinzip ist es quasi das, was du
in das Ticket geschrieben hast, nochmal.
Und unten drunter steht dann,
wenn diese Antwort hilfreich war,
bitte Ticket schließen.
Und dann musst du reinschreiben,
mein Microsoft Logo,
das hat irgendeiner hier im Chat gebaut,
und dann musst du in das Ticket
reinschreiben, nein, dass ihr schwach seid,
was ihr schreibt, das wissen wir doch schon alles,
jetzt kümmert euch mal ordentlich drum.
Das ist ja meistens was.
Fühlt man sich da nicht verarscht? Ja, schon.
Aber so ist das halt, wenn man für SLAs bezahlt
und nicht für die Lösung, letztendlich.
Das ist professionell Zeitschinden,
genau.
Ja, so läuft das. Aber
bei manchen Sachen
ist das sinnvoll.
Gerade beim ESX Support, beim VMware Support
habe ich das bei euch und bei uns
auch schon öfters mitgekriegt,
dass es tatsächlich sinnvoll ist, da was zu haben.
Und auch
bei unserem Dell Storage System
war es auch schon teilweise sinnvoll.
Übrigens, da habe ich mal so ein Video gemacht,
wen Wartungsarbeiten am Storage
interessieren,
kann sich mal
dieses Video angucken, da hatten wir noch
ein IBM Storage, wo das Firmware Update
ziemlich in die Hose gegangen ist.
Ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz,
so ein fertiges Storage System zu kaufen,
wenn man da irgendwie petabyteweise Daten hat,
ist gar nicht so blöd.
Also wenn
ein Unternehmen davon abhängt, wie bei
Linus, dann würde ich mir das echt überlegen.
Genau das Video,
ja, das Video, wo sie
einen USB-Stick in den Fahrstuhl geworfen haben,
korrekt.
So, gucken wir mal, fertig.
Was?
By the way, by the way, an der Stelle
auch nochmal angemerkt, ZFS
ist eine supergeile Technik, also wirklich
massive high-IQ-Technik,
aber das zu benutzen,
wenn man keine Ahnung davon hat, ist ziemlich sicher
Painschamp, auf Dauer.
Das ist auch der Grund,
warum
ich NFS wieder abgeschafft habe
bei mir daheim, weil
es zu,
ich sag mal so, zu
overkill und zu komplex war
für meine Anwendungszwecke.
Klar kannst du sagen,
du setzt das einmal
auf und dann funktioniert's,
aber die Sache ist halt
die, was ist, wenn
du, wenn mal wirklich was kaputt ist,
ja, was ist, wenn der beim re-silvern
oder so, wie das heißt bei NFS,
wenn das Ding irgendwie abkackt oder
was machst du wirklich, wenn ein Device down ist,
wie tauschst du das dann richtig aus,
wie machst du einen Snapshot wieder zurück und sonst wie was,
das ist gar nicht so easy.
Es sieht halt cool
auf den ersten Blick aus, weil ZFS
wahnsinnig nice Features hat,
du brauchst aber halt Ahnung davon und du brauchst am besten
auch Ahnung, dass du dich täglich damit auseinandersetzt,
dass du's noch weißt, wenn's denn dann soweit ist.
Deswegen hab ich's bei mir wieder abgeschafft. Egal, gucken wir jetzt mal fertig.
Das Rebuilden, ha!
Wisst ihr, was das Problem ist?
Das ist auch so eine Sache bei einem RAID.
Du merkst
oftmals, ob's richtig kaputt ist,
erst beim Rebuilden.
Warum? Naja, je nachdem,
wie das RAID-System aufgebaut ist, wird ja
das, was fehlt, aus Daten
restored, die über die anderen Platten
verteilt sind.
Das heißt, ob die anderen Platten alle
hundertprozentig funktionieren, merkt
du erst bei einem Rebuild, weil du nur bei einem Rebuild
Sektor für Sektor
von jeder anderen Platte quasi den
Kram wieder recoveren musst.
Deswegen geht's bei einem Rebuild oftmals
erst richtig kaputt.
Das sind so Sachen, das muss
einem alles klar sein, wenn man...
Ich hab das Video nicht gesehen.
Aber ich
predikte einfach mal, dass sowas jetzt kommt,
weil es eines der klassischen Fehler
schlechthin ist.
Ja, und außerdem bei hundert Platten
ist die Chance, dass was kaputt geht,
relativ hoch.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich vom...
...
Das bei ZFS ist halt der Vorteil, du merkst das, dass das passiert. Die Fehler hast du trotzdem noch, aber du merkst das halt, dank Checksummen und Zichtgedöns, dass das Probleme macht. Bei anderen Filesystems hast du dann das Ding, okay, du willst darauf zugreifen und es ist halt nicht mehr möglich oder nicht das, was du haben willst.
Oder ein Resync, was in dem Fall von ZFS bedeutet, dass jeder Block von Daten gecheckt wird, um sicherzustellen, dass es keine Fehler gibt. Und wenn es Fehler gibt, sind diese Fehler automatisch mit den Parodiedaten, die in der Array gestorben sind, festgelegt.
Bei den meisten NAS-Operationssystemen, wie TrueNAS, Unraid oder anderen pre-gestellten NAS, sollte dieser Prozess automatisch passieren. Und auch wenn nichts falsch geht, sollten sie auch jeden Monat einen geplante Scrub runtern.
Aber unsere Servern wurden von uns vor einem langen Zeitpunkt erstellt.
Da hast du schon mit das Problem. Hast du schon mal Refs benutzt? In Bezug auf was? Vue.js Refs? Das brauchst du in Vue.js 3. Also falls es um Vue.js geht. Refs ist quasi der neue Reactive-Way in Vue.js 3 Dinger zu machen.
Oder, hä? Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Hydralizer, danke schön für den Sub. Leute, übrigens hier die ganzen Subs, HugeMassive habe ich überhaupt nicht gesehen. Wolle hat auch subscribt.
Bleibt übersehen.
Ganz ehrlich, ganz, ganz im Ernst. Wenn wirklich mein Unternehmen, und deswegen glaube ich ihnen das immer nur zur Hälfte, ja, wenn wirklich mein Unternehmen von der Existenz dieses Fileservers abhängt, das hätte ich, das kann ich kaum glauben, dass man dann in solche Fallen tappt.
Power on Recovery Scrub was ever configured. Meaning the only time data integrity would have been checked on these arrays is when a block of data got...
Red.
Ja.
This function should theoretically protect against BitRod, but since we have thousands of old videos, of which a very, very small portion...
Vor allem ist die Chance, vor allem ist die Chance, wenn man da irgendwie, was weiß ich, hunderte von Festplatten drin hat, relativ groß, da muss man einfach nur nachgucken, wie hoch ist der durchschnittliche, also wie hoch ist die durchschnittliche Fehlerrate einer Festplatte, kann man beim Hersteller nachgucken, und dann guckst du einfach mal nach, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, bei 100 Platten, das zu schützen.
das passiert und da kommst du wahrscheinlich drauf,
dass dir im Durchschnitt irgendwie, was weiß ich,
alle zwei Wochen eine Platte
kaputt gehen müsste oder so.
Übrigens,
ihr müsst jetzt leider noch mal unterbrechen.
Übrigens, das ist so ein typischer Fall
von, RAID ist nicht immer besser.
Stellt euch
mal vor, der hätte einfach 100
Platten zusammengehängt.
Was wäre im
schlimmsten Fall passiert?
Also er hätte 100 Platten genommen
und hätte jetzt 5
Platten kaputt gehabt.
Er hätte, was weiß ich,
einen großen Windows-Ordner
da drauf gemacht, aber unter der Haube immer noch
just a bunch of disks oder wie man
irgendwie sagt. Was wäre im schlimmsten Fall
passiert?
Die Daten, die
auf diesen 5 Platten
waren, wären weg.
Aber der Rest wäre
immer noch da.
Wohingegen mit ihrem RAID-Konstrukt,
wenn das RAID failed,
ist alles weg.
Das sind alles so Dinge, die man beachten
muss und das ist tatsächlich nicht easy.
Und nicht von irgendwie,
wir frickeln mal ein bisschen nebenbei,
hobbytechnisch damit rum,
sinnvoll, konzeptionell
umgesetzt.
Das ist nicht so.
Da ist, manchmal ist es tatsächlich
ganz sinnvoll.
Ich sag nicht, dass ich es besser
könnte, ja.
Ich sag nur bei, dass ich,
dass ich mittlerweile weiß,
wann man sich da jemand holen
sollte, der wirklich Ahnung hat.
Ja, das muss,
das ist an sich nicht schlimm.
Ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist, ich weiß nicht, dass ich es nicht richtig weh hatte, aber ich habe mir in der
Sicht im Vergleich gesehen, dass ab und zu mal irgendwie was fehlt, ist ja normal, schwer
zu sagen.
Das ist, also ich kann jetzt schlecht einschätzen, ob das viel oder wenig ist, weil wenn man
zum Beispiel mal seine Netzwerk Interface Statistik anguckt, da wird man sehen, es gibt immer
mal Error, die da drauf sind und nix passiert.
Die ersten VDEVs, es gibt nicht genug Parodie-Daten, um die Fehler zu lösen.
Und das hat den Array, sich selbst offline zu schützen, gegen weitere Degradationen.
Und leider, viel weiter im Prozess, ist das gleiche Ding auf Delta-1 passiert.
Das bedeutet, dass beide, die originellen und neuen Petabyte-Projekte,
alte und neue Vault, nicht wiederholbare Daten verloren haben.
Also, was machen wir jetzt?
Wir machen erstmal ein Video drüber, wo wir angeblich zwingend den Pfeilsauber verbrauchen.
Wie gesagt, ich sag nicht, dass es fake ist oder so, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nur
drei Viertel der Wahrheit, was man da immer sieht.
Und das ist auch eine der ersten VDEVs, die wir in der Zeit haben.
Also, so nebenlastens, Sellout-Technisch hat er echt gut drauf.
...to move all of the data from the new Vault...
Hä? Und wie wollen sie jetzt die...
Das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Und wie wollen sie jetzt die Daten
vom Alten ins Neue kriegen, wenn das Alte doch
unrecoverable ist?
Unrecoverable ist?
Das war mir jetzt zu...
Das ging mir jetzt zu schnell.
Hä?
Ne, Revs habe ich noch nicht benutzt.
Er hat auch gerade erzählt,
die Raids sind kaputt
auf dem Alten.
So, und wie wollen
sie die Daten da wieder rauskriegen,
wenn das Raid kaputt ist?
Verstehe nicht.
Was, New World?
Ja.
Ja. Ja.
Genau.
Der Scheiß ist halt teuer.
Ja.
Ach.
Haha.
Ja.
Ich denke, es ist Mission-Critical, das hat er doch am Anfang erzählt.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es gibt ja noch theoretisch andere Möglichkeiten, also wenn man das wirklich in solchem Umfang machen will, vielleicht kann man sich irgendwo auch Co-Location-technisch einmieten und da einen Server hinstellen, auf dem man mirrored oder wie auch immer, aber dass das scheiß Geld kostet, ist ja logisch.
Es sollte in beiden solchen Fällen gebackt worden sein, aber all unsere archivierten Fotos vom ersten Tag des Kanals haben immer ein schönes zu haben und eine Entschuldigung für uns, wirklich coole Technik zu entdecken, mit der wir sonst keinen Grund haben, sie zu spielen.
Ich meine, es braucht ein bisschen mehr Arbeit und es erhält niedrige Qualitätsresultate, aber wir haben eine Backup von all unseren alten Videos. Es heißt Downloading them off of YouTube.
Oder Floatplane, wenn wir eine höhere Qualität Kopie wollen.
Also, das ist das.
Er hat nicht gesagt, dass die Dinger Mission Critical sind, aber er hat das ganz stark so formuliert.
Er hat gesagt, der File-Server, wo alle unsere Videodaten drauf sind.
So, nachdem er mit Videos quasi sein Geld verdient, gut, weiß ich nicht, wie viel das anteilmäßig ist mittlerweile.
Achso.
Also, im Prinzip war das Ding eigentlich komplett...
...überflüssig, oder wie?
Was da jetzt abgeraucht ist.
Genial.
Super.
Gut, also im Prinzip komplett...
...ben Arsch, ja?
Es ist eigentlich egal, ob es jetzt kaputt ist oder nicht.
Das ist super.
Die meldet.
Nur Zeit will erzählen.
Viele Zeit, weil die Transfers dieser Daten aus den Harddrives auf...
Hehehe.
Also entweder ist es super wichtig oder nicht und dann hätte man...
Hä? Ok.
Gebatet.
Ja.
Was hier ist dann auf...
Okay.
Ja die machen bestimmt mittlerweile sauviel Video, sauviel auch mit äh...
...irgendwie Produktion für andere Leute und so...
...aber, ah.
Sag mal was denkst du oftentimes?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ah ja, das ist interessant.
Guck mal.
Das finde ich interessant. Nice.
Video-Sponsorship-Merchandise.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Die Sponsoring im Video und Merchandise
ist die Hälfte. Das ist richtig
übel.
YouTube AdSense ist dann quasi noch ein Drittel.
Und der Rest ist andere Kram.
Interessant, ja.
Danke für den Sub.
So.
So, was? YouTube-Silver-Dislike-Button-Award.
Die Dislikes sind eh weg.
Ich hab sie zwar noch wegen dem Add-on,
aber wie genau die sind,
man weiß es nicht.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als
nächstes an?
Call of Duty. Level-Capture-Baden.
Ja, das muss sein.
Leute, Level-Capture-Baden.
Wir müssen uns einmalig im Sonntag-Stream
Level-Capture-Baden lassen.
Star Wars 1313-Gameplay
has leaked online.
Leaked?
Mittlerweile bin ich mir bei allen möglichen Leaks
gar nicht mehr so sicher, ob das alles wirklich
Leaks sind.
Auf Raid verlassen?
Okay, da muss ich jetzt was zu sagen, Chat.
Also, weder noch.
Auf Raid kannst du dich insofern nicht
verlassen, dass wenn du selbst aus Versehen
was löscht, dann ist es ja komplett weg.
Also, du musst eigentlich
beides machen, wobei du nicht wirklich
Airclone-Offsite-Cloudbacker,
haben musst, sondern du kannst einfach
über USB noch eine zweite
Platte dranhängen oder halt eine, was auch immer,
x-te Platte dranhängen, auf die du
einmal nachts Airclonst, Airsynxt
oder sonst was. Das kannst du machen.
Raid ist nur gut dafür,
dass du keinen Service-Ausfall
hast. Also sprich, wenn du, sagen wir mal,
einen Fileserver hast und möchtest, dass der
wirklich rund um die Uhr verfügbar ist,
auch wenn mal eine Platte kaputt geht,
dann machst du ein Raid, dass es eben nicht passiert.
Ansonsten
müsstest du halt irgendwie
kurz die Sachen vom Backup kopieren
oder sowas, ja. Aber wovor Raid
halt nicht schützt, ist, wenn du aus Versehen was
löscht oder wenn du ein
Verschlüsselungstrojaner hast oder was auch immer
in dieser Richtung. Das Raid
weiß das ja nicht. Das Raid schreibt das auf alle Platten
drunter, wenn es eine Schreib-
und Schreibanfrage bekommt.
Das heißt, das bringt dir nichts.
Du musst das backuppen.
Am besten und am billigsten
erst einmal auf irgendeine externe
USB-Platte oder sowas.
Kostet nicht wirklich viel,
und ist
unabhängig von deinem Raid. Kannst du theoretisch sogar
ausschalten dann. Machst einmal nachts an,
machst dein Backup über erst
so. So habe ich es ja bei mir auch mittlerweile.
Man kann die Sachen immer
verbessern, aber das Wichtigste ist, dass man überhaupt
einen Backup hat. Guck mal, man sieht es hier irgendwie.
Homeserver-Enjoyer. Ich habe doch hier irgendwo
ein Bild von meinem Server, wo die USB-Platte
oben drauf steht. Irgendwo.
Hier?
Hier.
Guck da.
10TB USB-Platte steht da einfach oben drauf.
Fertig.
Habt ihr einfach eine USB-Festplatte
und
da wird dann AirSync drauf nachts.
Easy.
Man könnte das noch deutlich schöner machen
mit
quasi so einem
automatischen Rotieren.
Hätte ich jetzt zum Beispiel
einen Verschlüsselungstrojaner
und ich würde es nicht merken,
bis das nächste Backup läuft, dann ist es dann halt gesynct.
Das wäre
natürlich noch besser, das so zu machen, dass du
sagst, hey, wir machen
sieben Tage Backup, dann
einmal im Monat und dann rotieren wir das
wie auch immer. Gibt es ja verschiedene Lösungen
für. Aber das Wichtigste ist, dass man
es erstmal macht. Es kann auch kacke gemacht
sein erstmal. Einfach blindes AirSync
einmal nachts vom
Server auf eine USB-Platte.
Das ist alles definitiv viel, viel besser
als gar kein Backup zu haben.
Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
QNAP, kein Schimmer.
Der Wallpaper.
Ja, das Dashboard habe ich nur
für das Video gemacht. Borg-Backup
habe ich auch eine Weile benutzt.
Das Problem
an Borg-Backup für mich war, also das ist ein
super Produkt für Hackermans,
dass ich
jedes Mal, wenn
ich was gebraucht habe
aus dem Backup, erstmal nicht wusste, wie man es bedient.
Weil ich es so selten benutzt habe.
Aber an sich ist das richtig
nice.
Ich muss mal einen Bonbon lutschen.
So, wir lassen uns jetzt mal von der
Level-Capture-Baiten.
Was ist Nam?
Ach, er wieder.
Er wieder. Das können wir uns
nachher auch noch angucken, ja.
Der macht immer nice Witz.
Weeps out.
Nam, weeps out.
So, schauen wir uns jetzt mal ein.
Wir lassen uns mal eine Runde Level-Capture-Baiten.
Ja, das würde mich nicht wundern.
Weil Caldera und
der, äh, was ist
das aktuelle? Vanguard?
Ich blick da schon gar immer durch.
Äh, Warzone
Refresh kam ja nicht
wirklich gut an.
Information emerged from a report by Bloomberg earlier
in the week detailing this next iteration
of the Smash Hit Battle Royale game.
The Bloomberg article listed Warzone
2 alongside the next three
Call of Duty releases all the way up to
2023. The focus of the article
was about Call of Duty releasing on
both Xbox and PlayStation consoles
for the next couple of years, so maybe
Warzone 2 wasn't really supposed to be
the main subject. Whether this
mention was intentional or not, it
does indicate a rough idea of
Activision's plans for the franchise.
Warzone 2 will apparently present
players with a completely fresh start.
A clean slate, if you will.
Ditching the game's past content
and mechanics in favor of something entirely
new. This narrative has been further
corroborated by industry insider
Tom Henderson.
Ah ja.
Wer sonst?
... are scarce right now, but we could assume
Raven Software will continue to lead
Warzone 2 development with help from
different support studios. Ravensoft
sind das nicht die, die es quasi
irgendwie, seit sie es übernommen haben,
permanent in Warzone verkacken?
So mit unsichtbaren Skins
und Dingern, die nicht laden
und sowas?
Also Ravensoft, die es die ganze Zeit eigentlich
verkacken?
It's also rumored that Warzone 2 will ship
exclusively on next-gen consoles,
but it is believed that this
is dependent on hardware
availability. Though when we go
beyond 2023's release schedule,
the format for Call of Duty
releases is less clear. We're not sure
if the new owners at Microsoft are going
to want Call of Duty launching on the
PlayStation platform anymore.
Werden sie wollen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass Call of Duty
auch weiterhin auf der PlayStation rauskommt, weil
das ist ja im Prinzip
so eine reine Business-Entscheidung.
Wenn man sich anguckt, wie viel Kohle das
bringt und wie viel Verkäufer das macht auf der
PlayStation, lohnt es sich dann
auf diese Verkäufe zu verzichten
für die Vorteile,
die man durch irgendwelche exklusiven Sachen
hätte. Und ich denke mal, dass das
zumindest kurzfristig erstmal Nein ist,
dass das nicht bedeutet, dass das
exklusiv sein wird.
Was ich mir vorstellen könnte,
ist genau sowas, was Captain Peng
gerade schreibt, dass es irgendwie eine Woche
früher vielleicht auf der Xbox kommt oder sowas.
Erstmal, wenn die nächste
Konsolengeneration kommt, ja das ist ja gar nicht
absehbar. Die PlayStation 5,
ist ja relativ neu, das heißt, das dauert vorneweg
fünf Jahre, bis die nächste kommt
und
dafür, dass die PlayStation 5 jetzt ja
irgendwie gefühlt auch schon eineinhalb Jahre oder so alt ist,
gibt es ja erstaunlich
wenige.
It's entirely possible, it may
become an Xbox and PC exclusive
down the road. New footage
of the cancelled Star Wars 1313
game has been unveiled
through the Battlefront 3 Archive
channel on YouTube called
The Vault. Star Wars 1313
was originally being developed by
LucasArts and entered its prototype
phase before Disney cancelled the project
in 2013. Since then,
various sources have leaked different
material online, concept art,
gameplay segments and other
assets. This week's gameplay depicts
the notorious Boba Fett in action
in two clips. The first shows
Boba Fett walking through crowded alleyways
and bars on the planet of Coruscant,
while the second clip shows off an intense
Rupin.
Ich sag euch, wie es ist, ihr wisst, ich bin kein großer Star Wars Fan,
geht mir am Arsch vorbei.
Take Viagra, die
hard. Alles klar.
Hard subscribed. Danke für den
Sub, IQ++. Ja, so sieht's aus.
The game world is untextured and unfinished, but
a lot of the movement mechanics and character
design is somewhat impressive.
Star Wars 1313 amassed a huge
following online at the time of its
reveal, which led to a lot of upset
fans once the game was actually shelved.
And with most Star Wars games based around
a playable Jedi character,
it's sad to think how great this
game could have been if it had shifted its
focus more toward the scum and
villainy of Coruscant. In brighter
Star Wars news though, the legacy
of the Sith expansion for the old
Republic goes live next week, and
the new story trailer hints at brand new
locations and characters. BioWare has
confirmed that the new locations that will
appear in this expansion include
the underwater facilities of the planet
of Maenon, the old Sith fortress
on Elam, and the R4
anomaly. This is a free
update to all subscribers of the old
Republic.
And it's set to launch on February 15th.
Developer Crytek announced the next iteration
of the Crysis franchise this week.
The CEO of Crytek shared that
this new game, with the working title
of Crysis 4, is still
in the early stages of development, so
it'll be a while as of yet.
Developers on the game hope to include the community
as much as possible by inviting players
to follow along with the development
through the game's social media channels.
Crytek is also currently hiring people
to work on the game's social media channels.
Crystis 1 was the best Crysis.
Change my mind.
...on this game and use the
new teaser trailer as a call for
talent. The Crysis franchise will celebrate
its 15th anniversary later this
year, so this teaser presumably
ties in with that as well.
Ubisoft have landed themselves in hot
water this week as Nicolas Poirard,
the VP at Ubisoft Strategic Innovations...
Ach ja, sie haben wieder erzählt,
sie haben wieder erzählt,
dass NFT das geilste ist, das habe ich schon
gelesen, ja. Ich... ich... ich...
Werte mit euch, der Ubisoft, die Ubisoft, die haben überhaupt keine Ahnung, was ein NFT bzw. was da überhaupt dahinter steckt und nicht dahinter steckt.
Wahrscheinlich denken die Ubisoft-Typen tatsächlich, es hat was mit irgendwelchen Ingame-Models und Bildern zu tun.
Patronized Gamers claiming that we didn't understand their new NFT endeavor.
Ubisoft announced Quartz as their NFT initiative that allowed players to buy artificially scarce digital items using cryptocurrency.
And this announcement was inevitably met with major backlash from fans and gamers.
Nicolas Poirard claims the blame for this backlash is with the players and not them.
Ja, ja gut, was heißt das Problem? Die Spiele haben ja recht.
Gamers don't really get what a digital secondary market can bring to them.
Ja, ja, ja klar.
Natürlich, natürlich, ich glaube hauptsächlich das Problem ist, weil die Leute sich ungefähr doch ganz gut erahnen können, was für eine Scheiße damit getrieben wird.
But they don't get it for now.
Natürlich, natürlich, die Leute sind einfach nur zu unterbemittelt, die Genialität zu verstehen dahinter.
Ja, ja, ja.
Once again, this has created even more backlash from the gaming community and it's unknown how Ubisoft will continue on.
Ich meine, ich gehe davon aus, dass den meisten Leuten, die darüber flamen, tatsächlich auch nicht ganz klar ist, was ein NFT ist und dass das mit Ingame-Models und Bildern eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat.
Aber die können aus den Praktiken...
der Jahre davor schließen, dass es egal, was es ist, für sie wahrscheinlich nichts Gutes bedeutet.
Hier, on top of this, Ubisoft has also announced the closure of the Hyperscape-Servers less than two years after the game's release.
Hyperscape shut it down! Das war glaube ich das Ubisoft Battle Royale, der Ubisoft Battle Royale Versuch.
Das ist vorbei, ja.
The Hyperscape Battle Royale game attempted to change the Battle Royale landscape with its reveal back in 2020.
Pitching itself as a free-to-play title, putting 100 players in squads of three all fighting and traversing a futuristic landscape in fast-paced action.
However, as of April 28th this year, servers will be taken offline, presumably due to the dwindling player count.
Now, on the flip side of dwindling player counts, Apex Legends is full steam ahead with a brand new launch trailer for Season 12, titled Defiance.
Season 12 will introduce a new legend named Maggie, a New Zealand-based legend with...
Apex hat so krass...
...krass viel Geld gemacht schon.
...alongside Maggie, Season 12 will add a new 9v9 mode called Control, a new Battle Pass, ranked season and celebratory giveaways since the game is turning three years old around the same time.
Der Charakter sieht aus wie irgendein Drogenabhängiger vom Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Not to mention, the Olympus map seems to be receiving a facelift as depicted in the launch trailer.
Season 12 drops on February 8th.
Guerrilla Games shared new gameplay snippets of...
...Horizon Forbidden West running on the PlayStation 5.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wann das rauskommt.
Es ist kein PC-Release angekündigt, oder?
Ich meine, das erste kam jetzt ja von nicht so langer Zeit auf dem PC.
Aber ich glaube, dafür wird es wahrscheinlich erstmal PlayStation-exklusiv bleiben.
...Marketing in the game as the PlayStation 5 is still so hard to get a hold of.
Posted on the PlayStation Blog, the new footage is shared through several GIFs, the gameplay shows the Utaru tribe's home in plain song and how the Red Blight is...
...infecting the lands as well as some new combat footage involving the Clamber Jaws and Bristlebacks.
With a February 18th release date, expectations are high for this beloved sequel.
It was confirmed in the same blog post that the game has finally gone gold, meaning it has reached its launch date.
Now the studio begins printing and distributing the game to retailers around the world.
Now done.
Destiny 2 developer Bungie has outlined more details on the game's upcoming expansion, The Witch Queen.
The update notes cover several notable mentions such as Vanguard Ops...
...and Destiny geht auch so ein bisschen an mir vorbei.
Spielt von euch jemand noch aktiv Destiny?
Ich muss sagen, ich habe nie großartig Destiny gespielt, aber würde mich mal interessieren, wie das so aktuell ist.
...and improvement.
High dynamic range and summary refers to screens that can...
Moment, Moment, wir müssen noch kurz...
...Destiny player count.
Da gab es doch, da gab es doch so eine coole Seite, wo man...
...Destiny-Spieler sich nach Plattform...
...War das das hier?
Ja, genau, Stadia ist immer noch bei 0%, oder?
War ja irgendwo klar, dass Stadia nicht wirklich mehr Spieler bekommen wird, oder?
Oh, 0,1%, uiuiui!
Ei, ei, ei, jetzt hat es aber, jetzt geben sie aber mal Gas, juhu!
Oh, guck mal hier, hä, warum ist hier bei Stadia so viel?
Oh man, Stadia, Alter.
Achso, das zeigt nur Leute an, die sich da auch angemeldet haben.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Also, es ist das Aussagekräftigste, was wir haben.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, wie sieht es eigentlich hier aus?
Wo wir uns gerade mal beim Fails bewegen.
6.500, vor der Woche waren wir noch bei knapp unter 10.000.
Man fragt mich, wann wir bei unter 1.000 ankommen, ey.
Das ist, das ist ja wirklich mies, Alter.
Oh, ist das schlecht, ist das schlecht, meine Güte, ist das kacke.
Guckt euch das mal an, Alter.
Oh, es ist sogar wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen, weil Wochenende ist.
Aber, jetzt kommen die Leute wieder und sagen, Max, das ist doch überhaupt nicht aussagekräftig, das ist doch nur Steam.
Das Game gibt es doch auch noch auf Konsolen und gibt es doch auch noch auf Origin und sonst was.
Was?
Wirklich, der Trend wird da wahnsinnig anders aussehen?
Also, aus welchen Gründen sollte der Trend entgegengesetzt sein auf den anderen Plattformen?
Fällt mir jetzt kein Grund ein.
Oh, ist das schlecht, Alter.
Ja, dass man das auch gegen Bots freischalten, das ist so fehl.
Wie sieht es eigentlich aus, Twitter?
Battlefieldcom.
Was gibt es denn da sonst?
Was gibt es da so Neues, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Ein solches Business as usual, ja.
Wir sehen die Decrease.
Ach so, ich dachte, Player Numbers.
Es ist einfach, oh Mann, Battlefield.
Oh, die Twitter-Trends, da habe ich gar nicht reingucken.
So, und wie sieht es bei New World aus?
Bestimmt auch nicht besser.
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Das ist ja noch krasserer Absturz als Battlefield, Alter.
Wir sind jetzt bei unter 80.000, nice.
Im Februar soll jetzt auch ein Scoreboard kommen, habe ich schon gehört, ja.
Legacy-Feature, das wird das Game bestimmt retten.
Oh Mann, so ein verkackter Kack, ja.
Aber echt, ja, guck mal, wobei, Destiny juckt mich eh nicht, juckt mich auch nicht.
Okay, nice, fertig, next.
Was ist das denn?
Microsoft zerstört Windows 11 mit Werbung.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Heute sprechen wir über ein ernsthaftes Problem in Windows 11.
Ja, das hätte ich nicht verstanden, wenn das nicht als Buchstaben unten eingeflogen wäre.
Werbung in Windows 11.
Windows hat nämlich besorgniserregende Ausmaße angenommen.
In diesem Video sprechen wir darüber, was aktuell bei Microsoft schiefläuft,
wie euch das als Nutzer betrifft und was ihr gegen die viele Werbung im Betriebssystem...
Lass mich raten, irgendwelche komischen Registry-Hacks, wie das unter Windows immer so ist.
Moment, sind das nicht auch der, ist das nicht der Channel,
die dieses Tuning-Pack mal angepriesen haben, wo wir uns das angeschaut haben?
Nee, das sind andere, gell?
Nee, nee, das sind andere, das sind andere.
Ich glaube, die hier waren ganz gut.
Ich glaube, die hier waren ganz gut vom Content.
Zuvor müssen wir allerdings über gescheiterte Pläne sprechen.
Denn die sind wichtig, um zu verstehen, warum wir gerade jetzt in Windows 11 immer mehr Blödsinn aufgezwungen bekommen.
Schon seit Windows 10 verfolgt Microsoft nämlich eine Windows-as-a-Service-Strategie.
Man gibt uns, also den Nutzern, unendlich viele Windows-Updates praktisch kostenlos, verlangt dafür allerdings für Premium-Gesetz.
Naja, das Problem ist...
Das Problem ist nur, dass die meisten Sachen, die da in den Updates kommen, jetzt nicht unbedingt das ist, was die Leute gefragt haben.
Ist ja etwas Geld.
Du hast dann zum Beispiel mein absolutes Lieblings-Feature, also in Anführungsstrichen Lieblings-Feature war ja immer noch,
wo auf einmal, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo auf einmal hier unten rechts irgendeine Wetterbar aufgetaucht ist.
Random!
Du hast ein Update gemacht, auf einmal hast du irgendwie so eine super schlecht implementierte Wetteranzeige hier unten rechts in der Taskbar.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, wo die hin ist, die ist wahrscheinlich wieder weg.
Die Dienste wären zum Beispiel der Cloud.
Cloud-Speicher OneDrive, Office 365, der PC Game Pass, Käufe aus dem Microsoft Store, wo Microsoft früher mal 30% Provision einkassiert hat.
Und im Idealfall natürlich Microsofts einziger Musik-Streaming-Dienst, Groove Music.
Es ist eigentlich ein direktes Abbild von den Premium-Diensten, welche auch Apple bietet.
Aber der iPhone-Hersteller hat mit seinem ausgeklügelten Ökosystem ein deutlich besseres Argument gebaut, um deren Dienste auch tatsächlich zu verwenden.
Ja, das Microsoft-Zeug will irgendwie keiner.
Ja.
Und da brauchen wir entsprechend deren Dienste kaum bis gar nicht.
Und viele Bemühungen, durch Dienste in Windows 10 Geld einzuheben, sind ganz einfach gescheitert.
Benutzt du Windows 11?
Nein, das ist nur Windows 10.
Nature-Enthusiast, take this park-squiz.
Ja, genau, Nature-Enthusiast.
Mit Windows 11 hebt der Microsoft Store zum Beispiel keine Provisionen mehr ein.
Office 365 ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich ein Muss, um Windows 11 benutzen zu können.
Groove Music wurde eingestellt und auch Skype.
Könnte praktisch eingestellt werden, ohne dass es jemand merkt.
Microsofts Dienstestrategie hat abseits...
Wann habt ihr das letzte Mal Skype verwendet?
...von Office und Xbox...
Also bei mir ist das bestimmt fünf Jahre her.
...die Grunde versagt, da man einfach nicht das Ökosystem anbieten kann, wo man deren Dienste bräuchte.
Also musste ein anderes Zugpferd her und leider ist es einer meiner Lieblingsprodukte von Microsoft.
Der Microsoft Edge Browser.
Wegen seiner Synchronisation mit der Handy-Version, welche ich für einen integrierten Edge-Blocker liebe.
Eine in meinen Augen gefühlt bessere...
...in Privatsphäre, weil ich Microsoft immerhin mit den Daten mehr vertraue als Google.
Denn Profilen sowie den Sammlungen, die ich fast täglich benutze, finde ich den Edge-Browser auf Chromium-Basis fantastisch.
Okay, jedem, was er so will.
Seit es den Edge auf Chromium gibt, bin ich ein begeisterter Edge-Nutzer.
Aber während die Entwicklung sehr positiv begonnen hatte, mit einzigartigen Features wie dem Tracking-Schutz, den Sammlungen und vertikalen Tabs,
konzentrieren sich die Verbesserungen von Edge in letzter Zeit nur auf eine Sache.
Microsoft baut immer mehr Werbung ein.
Hier ist ein Beispiel.
Ihr ändert eure Suchmaschine und stellt ein paar Einstellungen um.
Wenn man nicht explizit auf kein Interesse klickt, kommt bei jedem Edge-Start diese Meldung wieder.
Echt?
Ich schlägt euch vor, Microsoft...
Zack.
Ich hab das ewig nicht aufgehabt.
Was?
Assist?
Nein.
Und jetzt?
Let's go.
Fuck.
Google.
Wir googeln über DuckDuckGo.
Perfekt.
Aber wahrscheinlich habe ich es irgendwann schon mal akzeptiert hier.
... Microsofts empfohlene Einstellungen für Edge zu übernehmen.
Warum?
Nun, die Antwort ist ganz einfach.
Microsoft möchte hauptsächlich, dass die Standard-Suchmaschine wieder Bing wird und nicht jede eurer...
Ja, nur Bing wird kein Mensch verwenden.
... das steht direkt drunter im Kleingedruckten.
Aber das ist wieder so eine dumme, lästige Meldung, die ihr wegklicken müsst.
Oder im Bestfall für Microsoft.
Lest ihr sie nicht mal.
Und klickt auf Übernehmen, nur damit sie eben verschwindet.
Schwupps, ist eure Suchmaschine wieder Bing.
So eine Scheiße.
Aber auch Nutzer, die bereits einen anderen Standard-Browser gewählt haben, denen legt Microsoft nur noch Steine in den Weg.
So zeigt Windows 11 in letzter Zeit solche Meldungen als Fullscreen-Popup.
Oh nee.
Klickt ihr auf die von Microsoft empfohlene Einstellung, dann ist euer Standard-Browser wieder Edge.
Obwohl der Nutzer ganz bewusst...
Diese Taktik wird mir auch auf den Sack gehen.
... den Browser zuvor geändert hat.
Und wer die Suche im Windows 11 Startmenü nutzt oder aus dem Widget-Menü eine Nachrichtenmeldung lesen möchte, der wird...
Seriously, verwendet dieses Widget-Menü irgendjemand?
... wird immer zum Microsoft...
Ich finde, das ist so eine ultra-überflüssige Entwicklung.
Genauso überflüssig wie dieses komische mit Dingen hier neben rechts.
... Edge-Browser weitergeleitet.
Egal welchen Standard-Browser ihr ausgewählt habt.
Und obwohl ich Edge nutze und auch eigentlich ein Fan davon bin, finde ich solche Dinge aufdringlich und einfach scheiße.
Aber der Spaß hört da natürlich nicht auf.
Microsoft versucht nicht nur zunehmend mit einem höheren Bing-Traffic für mehr Werbeeinnahmen zu sorgen,
sondern hat offenbar auch viel mehr Potenzial erkannt, ordentlich Cash zu machen.
Nun gibt es beispielsweise schon eine Microsoft-Shopping-Integration.
Diese empfiehlt euch Coupons, wenn ihr auf einer Seite eines Online-Shops rumscrollt,
ähnlich wie das Honey und andere Dienste machen.
Natürlich verdient der Anbieter dieser Coupons auch eine schöne Affiliate-Provision,
wenn ihr einen von ihren Coupons benutzt.
Aber die Chance ist nicht so groß.
Da die schlimmste und an Dreistigkeit nicht zu übertreffende Integration ist die Partnerschaft von Microsoft mit SIP,
einem Anbieter für sogenannte Buy-Now-Pay-Later-Lösungen.
Bei Zahlungen im Internet...
Pay... Pay... Now... Was? Buy-Now-Pay-Later? Hört sich nach einem Kredit an.
Also Buy-Now-Pay-Later?
Das ist bestimmt ein Kredit, aber schön für Zoomer verpackt, oder?
Zoomer-Kredit heißt nicht mehr Kredit.
Hätt noch, danke für den Sub.
Bei Zahlungen im Internet,
kann euch Microsoft also vorschlagen,
euren Kauf über einen Drittanbieter in Raten aufzuteilen,
weil ihr das nötige Geld nicht sofort aufbringen könnt.
Euer Browser dreht euch somit einen Kreditvertrag an.
Und da mit der Problematik dieser Null-Prozent-Finanzierungen vertraut ist,
würde es sehr wahrscheinlich die Finger davon lassen.
Das sind sehr oft ganz problematische Verträge, die da gerne verknüpft werden.
Sowas hat meiner Meinung nach in einem Webbrowser nichts zu tun.
Aber für Microsoft ist es eine sehr lukrative Möglichkeit,
seine wachsende Nutzerbasis in Edge zu Geld zu machen.
Und der Konzern zeigt auch, dass man offenbar die Zerreißlichkeit hat, genau das auch zu tun.
Aber das ist nur meine Meinung.
All das, also der Edge-Zwang in den Widgets, die nervigen Empfehlungen im System,
sowie die Vorschläge für die Suchmaschine, sollen die Leute von Google zu Bing bringen.
Windows 11 soll die Nutzung von Edge steigern und Edge anschließend die Suchmaschine bingen.
Das wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht passieren.
Das soll die Nutzung von Edge steigern und Edge anschließend die Suchmaschine bingen.
Mehr Traffic auf Bing bedeutet mehr Relevanz im Werbemarkt.
Und das bedeutet, Anzeigen auf Bing werden wertvoller.
Also das Einzige, wofür ich Bing verwende, ist für Image of the Day für meinen Linux-Hintergrund.
Das ist alles.
Wiederum für Microsoft selbstverständlich mehr Cash.
Und nachdem niemand Bing wirklich benutzen will, weil die Suchmaschine einfach schlecht ist,
so dreht man uns in der Zwischenzeit zu...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Bing wirklich schlecht ist.
Die anderen funktionieren gut genug, dass ich gar nicht nachdenke.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Bing wirklich schlecht ist, dass ich gar nicht nachdenke.
Ich benutze DuckDuck Go schon seit Jahren.
Und Google natürlich.
Und eigentlich habe ich überhaupt keinen Bedarf für Bing.
... und verdient etwas Geld mit Coupons.
Für einen Browser, welcher mit einem Betriebssystem mitgeliefert ist, ist sowas echt lächerlich.
Ja. Ja. Gerne mich überreicht.
Ja. Gerne mich überrecht.
Windows 11 deaktivieren könnt.
Angefangen von den nervigen Benachrichtigungen im System
bis hin zur genannten Edge-Problematik
und wie man diese eben löst.
Microsoft muss allerdings verstehen,
dass dieses Verhalten von Nutzern nicht
toleriert wird, weswegen wir einen
Feedback-Hub-Eintrag erstellt haben, dem ihr
auf jeden Fall eure Stimme geben solltet.
Ja, da sagt Microsoft jetzt direkt
abgelehnt.
Den Link dazu unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Feedback-Hub,
wo kommt man da jetzt raus,
wenn man da drauf drückt?
Darf man das überhaupt mit Chrome
aufmachen? Ja, dann nicht.
Mein Fake-Account
wurde geblockt. Oh nein!
Was besonders für Laptop-Nutzer
relevant, beziehungsweise auch
negativ relevant sein könnte.
Ich persönlich benutze...
Negativ relevant?
Kann im Zweifelsfall auf die Akku
auf die Laufzeit gehen.
Wirklich gern. Aber Microsofts Verhalten
geht mir schon in eine sehr dreiste Richtung.
Und wenn sich daran nichts ändert,
werde ich persönlich darüber nachdenken,
einen anderen Browser zu verwenden.
Einfach ausprobieren.
Oder erst gar nicht mit Edge anfangen.
... noch sagen, ich verstehe,
warum Microsoft das macht.
Google ist dominant beim Browser
sowie bei der Suchmaschine und Microsoft
will etwas von diesem Werbekuchen haben.
Aber ich finde, Microsoft versucht es
nicht wirklich damit, sein Produkt
also Bing und seine Dienste besser
zu machen, sondern drangsaliert Nutzer
sie eben zu verwenden, obwohl sie
das offensichtlich nicht möchten.
Nein, Microsoft, ich habe nicht zufällig
meine Suchmaschine tief versteckt
in den Einstellungen des Browsers geändert.
Und natürlich verstehe ich, dass man die Entwicklung
eines Betriebssystems sowie eines Browsers
irgendwo finanzieren muss.
Bei Android und Google Chrome ist die Sache...
Naja, da muss man sagen,
Microsoft hat Geld as fuck.
Die haben erst letztens Activision gekauft.
Die haben einen Gewinn im Jahr,
der ist irgendwie mehr als Netflix,
Amazon und...
äh, nicht Amazon, sorry.
Netflix, Nvidia und...
Was war es?
Netflix, Nvidia und noch irgendwas zusammen.
Und...
Also, Geldprobleme haben
die wirklich schnell.
...recht offensichtlich. Mozilla macht es über seine Stiftung
und Opera sowie Brave machen das
über Deals mit Suchmaschinenanbietern
und natürlich über Werbung, also jene
Seiten, die man standardmäßig im Browser
angepinnt hat. Zum Beispiel
Hotels.com und so.
Microsoft will über Edge die Reichweite
von Bing steigern und die langfristige
Entwicklung seines Windows-Betriebssystems
damit finanzieren. Denn für Windows monatlich
was zu bezahlen, das fällt niemanden ein.
Und nachdem die PC-Neuanschaffungen
immer seltener werden,
und Hardware deutlich länger aktuell bleibt,
verdient man mit Lizenzgebühren
deutlich weniger, als man das einst gemacht hat.
Aber...
Der Weg zur Steigerung
des Marktanteils von Edge
und auch von Bing führt über die
Verbesserung des Angebots.
Der Edge-Browser hat auch seine bisherigen Fans
und Nutzer wie mich über Qualität
bekommen, dank innovativer Features
und kleiner Verbesserungen und nicht
per Zwang. Denn der Zwang
hat nur eine Folge, er schadet dem Image
und dürfte auch Kartellbehörden
nicht wirklich egal sein.
So, das war's dann auch schon von mir
und von diesem Video.
Exzellent, ja, da gebe ich dem Volk ganz recht.
Opera ist doch nur ein Trojaner,
also gehört auf jeden Fall irgendwelchen
China-Chinesen, ja.
Ja, die haben richtig viel Geld.
Hm. Es braucht
eigentlich eine eingesteuerte neue Web-Render-Engine.
Ich weiß nicht, so Firefox zum Beispiel.
Ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir nicht sowas.
Wobei es Mozilla...
Also, was mit den Mozilla-Leuten
los ist, verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, die schaffen es tatsächlich
seit den letzten fünf, fünf
bis, ach, eigentlich schon
länger,
fünf bis zehn Jahren, ihren Browser
kontinuierlich schlechter zu machen
und kontinuierlich quasi das,
was Firefox ausgezeichnet hat, ja,
beispielsweise die riesen Add-on-Auswahl,
die vielen Sachen, die du machen konntest mit
Add-on, was nicht alles gab, so quasi einen Browser
für Technik, wie auch immer,
äh,
Enthusiasten zu haben,
haben die ja nach
und nach
ausgebaut und verschlimmbessert.
Guckt euch nur mal dieses Kack-Menü hier an.
Weiß nicht, was mit Mozilla los ist.
Mario, danke für den Sub.
IRQ-Subscription.
Massive, crazy Lego-Build.
Okay, zeig her.
Ich lass mal die Musik an.
Huge.
So weit wäre ich auch noch gekommen.
Ja, es wird schon schwierig langsam.
Okay, das Chat, das kriegen wir auch noch
alles hin. Warum hat er dafür
eigentlich seine krassen Handschuhe an?
Darf man die nicht touchen, die Lego
Bricks?
Die Klemmbausteine?
Was gibt es, wenn es fertig ist?
Würde es die Modes etwas verkleinern?
Tactical Lego-Building-Handschuhe.
Alles klar.
Ja, und jetzt?
Da ist ein Loch. Ich sehe es genau.
Kaputt. Der Chat wieder.
Noch habe ich keine wirkliche
Vorstellung, was es geben soll, wenn es fertig ist.
Außer einen
grünen, gelben Block.
Und noch einen grünen, gelben Block.
Noch einen grünen Block.
Grün, gelben Block.
Na, irgendwas muss es ja damit sein.
Das wird nicht einfach nur ein Block sein.
Ah.
Ah, okay. Verstehe.
High-IQ-Block.
Ach so. Okay, das hätte ich gar nicht
daraus erkannt. Aha.
Jetzt. Okay.
Das hätte ich nicht erkannt, was er da baut.
Das ist ein flexibler Block.
Ein flexibler Block.
Weiter.
Ah, jetzt baut er einen Ring draus.
Guck mal, da steht auch irgendwas von Brick Builder
drauf auf den Handschuhen.
Das ist dann wirklich der quasi
High-IQ-Lego-Bilder.
Der hat solche Handschuhe.
Noch eins.
Ah.
Nee. Nee.
Sieht aus wie ein Luftfilter. Ja, stimmt schon.
Sieht wirklich
ein bisschen aus. Er hat quasi das Rad
neu erfunden.
Naja, gut. Also.
Massive Crazy Lego-Bild.
Ich meine, das ist eine coole Sache mit diesen
flexiblen Dinger.
Aber ob das jetzt so Massive Crazy
und weiß nicht.
Ersatzreifen.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
Ja. Ich meine,
das ist ein Lego-Reifen.
Teuer ist das wahrscheinlich,
weil du so viele Teile dafür brauchst.
Ja.
Okay. Naja, gut.
So. Also, so krass vom
Hogger.
So krass vom Hogger haut es mich jetzt nicht.
Kostet mehr als ein richtiger Reifen.
Wahrscheinlich. So teuer wie der Lego-Kram
es ist.
Wobbel, wobbel, wobbel.
Ziemlich, ziemlich
Koggers das Ganze.
Aha.
Okay. Alles klar.
Gut, gut, dass wir uns das angeguckt
haben. Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid, falls ich mal einen
Lego-Reifen bauen will. Dann ist klar.
Has EA
lost Faith in Dice?
Ich hätte
schon. Theoretisch,
wenn ich bei EA wäre, hätte
ich schon nach der ersten Demo wahrscheinlich
Faith in Dice verloren. Aber okay.
Self-Hosting Security Guide.
Modern Warfare 2.
Ja, das ist mir egal.
Okay. Has EA lost
Faith in Dice? Zeig mal her.
Acht Minuten. Das können wir uns schnell geben.
Oh, ne.
Das ist Dings hier, oder?
Da hat er so eine geile Aussprache.
EA.
Der hat so eine
geile Aussprache, Alter.
Explain.
Okay. Er hat
diesmal auch keine Ahnung. Macht einfach ein Video drum.
Alles klar. Oh, ne. Das skippen wir.
Was?
Self-Hosting Security Guide
for your Homelab. Okay.
Wer ist das?
Moment. Moment. Ist das der Typ?
Ist das nicht der
Typ, wo wir uns letztens
ein Video von angeguckt haben,
der irgendwie
drei Proxmox Server
und Kubernetes Cluster
und sonst was hat, nur
um darauf im Endeffekt nichts laufen zu haben?
Ich erinnere mich.
Das war doch ein Video,
wo ich gesagt habe, eigentlich an Sinnlosigkeit
kaum zu überbieten.
Okay, der erklärt uns heute, wie man
unser Homelab sicher machen. Zeig mal her.
Most people think about self-hosting services in their
Homelab. They often focus
and only think about the last mile.
And by last mile, I mean the last
hop before a user accesses your
server.
Naja, im Homelab ist es meistens
so zwischen User, der meinen Server
accesst. Jetzt, da gibt es nicht so viele.
Das bin ja meistens ich oder irgendjemand anderes,
der hier im Haus wohnt.
Ist jetzt nicht so, als müsste ich mir da großartig Gedanken
drum machen. Was hat er da eigentlich für High IQ
Ausdrucke liegen?
This last hop, whether it's using certificates
or reverse proxy, is incredibly important.
Die Musik ist übrigens nicht von mir,
die hört sich an wie von mir, aber
das ist bei ihm im Video.
But it's also important to know that security starts
at the foundation of your Homelab.
Take for instance this diagram.
This most likely makes up most things in your Homelab.
Whether that be physical or virtual,
you'll find that you have most of these components.
Ist das so? Ist das so?
Ja, ich hab ne Festplatte, das ist
richtig, ja. Ich hab nen Handy.
Das ist
Hacker Bob.
Und Coggers hat er auch, guckt.
Wobei unser Coggers definitiv
besser ist als sein Coggers, ja.
So.
But what if I told you your Homelab should
look like this? That might seem
Ist das so? Okay, okay.
Was sehen wir hier? Wir sehen ein
Smartphone, ein
Wifi
oder so?
Weiß man nicht, Netzwerk?
Eine
Firewall?
Ein
Ah,
das ist VPN-Access, oder?
Ist das VPN-Access?
Ja, warum ist dann intern auch nochmal ne Cloud?
Ist das, soll
das hier VPN-Access sein?
Telefon,
Internet, quasi
Eingang, VPN, was auch immer,
internes Netzwerk, nochmal irgendwie
Server, und dann, ja, okay.
Das ist quasi so ne Art
DMZ, und das hier
intern, ich vermute mal, so was möchte er uns
damit sagen.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Was ist das?
Ein Adblocker?
Ja.
Zeig uns.
Die DDoS-Rakete fliegt.
Cloudflare.
All the way down to the hardware.
Was hat, ich überleg gerade,
was genau hat
Cloudflare
mit meinem
Homelab zu tun?
Mir fällt da nicht so viel ein,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich verwende Cloud, den
Cloudflare DNS
für meine Zertifikate, okay,
aber, tja.
And speaking of hardware,
Okay, wir können skippen. Ja, erstmal
Werbung drinne.
So, what's the best way of protecting yourself
while self-hosting?
Don't. Just don't do it.
Seriously.
Five hat time.
Aber das ist dumm, wenn man das nicht macht,
weil dann muss man seine Sachen über die China-Chinesen-Cloud
laufen lassen. Und ich habe so meine Zweifel,
dass die weniger in meinem Interesse handeln,
als ich selbst.
Nein, da ist ja gerade der Witz
dabei. Wenn man eine,
äh, wenn man Sachen daheim betreibt,
niemand zwingt ein,
dass dem Internet
zu exposen.
Warum soll ich das überhaupt machen?
Also sprich, wenn ich daheim irgendwas
laufen habe, ja, von
einem Fileserver
bis zu einem Wiki,
bis zu irgendwie Notizen
und To-Do's,
Kalender und was auch immer,
ich muss das doch nicht
ins Internet exposen.
Warum tun die Leute immer so,
teilweise in solchen Videos,
sobald ich daheim irgendwie den Raspberry Pi hinstelle,
ist der im Internet. Ist er doch gar nicht.
Was denn?
Webseiten selber hosten? Ja, das würde ich nicht machen.
Aber es geht ja hier um, es geht ja hier
irgendwie um Sachen, die man für daheim
braucht. Meine externe Webseite
hoste ich bestimmt nicht daheim.
Eins muss man immer lassen,
er hat sich hier Mühe gegeben mit seinem tief,
tiefen Unschärfe und Hintergrund.
Disclaimer.
Ja, dafür,
dafür bin ich ja da jetzt.
Ja.
Okay, das sollte wirklich ein VPN sein.
Ja, hat er recht.
Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Ja. Ja, das würde ich,
da gebe ich ihm insofern recht, würde ich auch nicht machen.
Also Sachen, die ich wirklich
von jedem Public
erreichbar haben will, die würde ich nie
bei mir daheim hosten und schon gar nicht
intern irgendwo bei mir daheim.
Also in irgendeinem internen Netz.
Ausrufezeichen Hetzer in Chat für meinen,
nee, nee, stimmt, das gilt ja dieses Jahr gar nicht mehr.
Ich muss,
ich muss mit denen auch mal besprechen,
was wir dieses Jahr noch machen.
Falls wir dieses Jahr was machen.
Ja.
Most people think of the last mile when self-hosting services starts this path right here.
But security starts at a much deeper level.
So rather than focus on this last hop right here, we're going to zoom in and focus on
the server that's running your services.
You typically don't think of the hardware when you're hosting applications in the cloud.
You really don't have to.
But since we're hosting in our own personal cloud, we do need to consider this.
The biggest takeaway here is to be sure that the hardware that your application is running
on are patched with the latest firmware.
This includes firmware for the server itself.
Ja, ja, ja, insofern gebe ich ihm recht, spätestens seit Spectre und Meltdown und sowas
ist es tatsächlich nicht verkehrt, darauf zu achten, dass man die aktuellste, aber nochmal,
ja, früher hätte ich gesagt, es ist eigentlich wurscht, aber ja, warum nicht, ja.
For devices like the motherboard, hard drives, network adapters and any other devices.
Habt ihr schon jemals die Firmware einer Festplatte gepatcht?
Ich noch nie.
Ich habe legit noch nie einen Firmware-Update meiner Festplatte und meiner SSD gemacht.
Noch nie.
Und mir war bis jetzt, habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, dass man das machen müsste.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht, keine Ahnung.
Klar, ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es Updates gibt bei, bei manchen, für manche
SSD-Controller oder so.
Dass das geht, dachte ich, ich habe da noch nie dran gedacht, das zu machen, ja.
Stimmt, bei den allerersten oder einer der ersten Samsung-SSDs gab es mal Probleme.
Ja, stimmt.
Das beste ist, so einfach wie möglich.
Das wird ihm jetzt vielleicht nicht gefallen, weil wie gesagt, das ist ja auch ein bisschen
wie gesagt, er hatte irgendwie 20, 20 VMs und irgendwie zwei Kubernetes-Cluster und
sonst was für sich daheim, wo ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe, warum er die eigentlich
hat, aber letztendlich die, die, die beste Antwort für Sachen daheim ist, so simpel
wie möglich, weil ihr beschäftigt euch nicht jeden Tag mit der Infrastruktur bei euch daheim.
Ihr wollt ja eigentlich, dass es möglichst vor sich hin läuft und funktioniert.
Das heißt, wenn ihr mal was machen müsst, umso einfacher es ist, umso schneller seid
ihr auch wieder fertig.
Und macht nicht im Zweifelsfall auch noch irgendwas kaputt.
Ja, also natürlich kann man sich irgendwie eine wilde Mischung aus, wo wir vorhin das
Video von Linus mit dem Storage-Server gesehen haben, klar, kann man sich eine wilde Mischung
aus zehn Festplatten mit ZFS und Verschlüsselung und hast du nicht gesehen und allem Gedöns
basteln, wenn es aber auch einfach eine externe Festplatte mit USB tut, auf die man regelmäßig
kopiert, ist das für den Heimbereich mit Sicherheit die sinnvollere Variante, weil es
die einfachere Variante ist.
Und man noch am ehesten durchblickt, wenn mal was nicht funktioniert.
Hast du bei dir VMs oder Container?
Ich habe beides.
Ich habe eine VM laufen für Home Assistant mit ein paar USB Sachen durchgereicht und
ich habe Container laufen für das Wiki und andere Sachen.
Aber da kannst du das Video von mir angucken, weil ich habe, ups, ich habe doch letztens
auch ein Video zu diesem Thema gemacht.
Guck mal, da habe ich doch gezeigt, Homeserver-Enjoyer.
Da habe ich doch gezeigt, was ich hier am Start habe.
Ich habe ein Doku-Wiki, Sachen für Fernsehaufnahmen, mein Home Assistant, das ist die VM, Übersicht
meiner Kameras, Octoprint für einen 3D-Drucker, das Unify-Dashboard, Monitoring, ein Passwort-Manager,
uralt Grafana, was ich nicht mal für einen nutze, Quellcode-Verwaltung, Adblocker, Analytics
für ein paar Websites, Nextcloud, die ich nicht abkann, aber die ich immer noch im Einsatz
habe und eine Hardware-Verwaltung, die ich kaum verwende.
Ja, das sind alles Container.
Der Home Assistant.
Der Home Assistant ist allerdings VM, Gigachat am Start, ja.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ein weiterer Punkt dafür, warum man es so wenig komplex wie möglich machen will, damit
man hier noch den Überblick behält und dass man nicht irgendwie, ja man muss sich da halt
regelmäßig drum kümmern.
Und da hat man, habe ich daheim keinen Bock drauf, das soll einfach funktionieren.
Ja.
Ich
vergesse.
Der Home Assistant, der Home Assistant kommt doch hervorragend fertig.
Gut.
Wir benutzen immer nur, da sind wir uns ja einig, wir benutzen immer nur sonst nix.
Immer Ubuntu-Server.
Windows, Alter.
Die Home Assistant vor allem als....
Ja.
denen darunter laden kann, das fix und fertige. Windows, wer macht denn sowas? Arch, by the way,
ist das einzig wahre. Warum?
Ich muss den Kram noch administrieren. Jaja, in der Theorie, in der Theorie.
Naja, regelmäßig, regelmäßig pullen wäre auch bei Containern nicht, sagen wir mal, schlecht,
aber da bin ich zu faul für, solange der Kram funktioniert, sag ich ganz ehrlich. Und nachdem
ich meinen Kram ja wirklich nur intern betreibe und nichts von außen erreichbar ist, sehe ich da
ein Problem. Zwergcringer sagt übrigens, nicer Name, by the way, der Zwergcringer sagt,
bei mir in der Arbeit ist Windows Standard. Ihr macht .NET Zeug. Wir in der Java-Abteilung sind
einzigen, die mit Linux arbeiten, ja, beste. Zumal man mittlerweile .NET Core unter Linux
besser entwickeln kann als unter Windows, finde ich. Ich benutze ja auch zum größten Teil .NET
für die meisten Sachen, die ich mache und das mache ich exklusiv unter Linux.
Ja, Watchtower ist nicht so einfach. Du kannst, habe ich auch installiert,
habe ich auch installiert, funktioniert zum größten Teil, aber es kommt immer mal wieder vor,
gerade bei Doku-Wiki, die sich da nicht mit Ruhm bekleckern, dass das nach einem Update auf einmal
dann nicht mehr verfügbar ist und du erst mal gucken musst, was Sache ist. Ja. Deswegen ist
auch wichtig, dass man nicht immer Latest nimmt bei den Containern, sondern irgendeinen Stable-Tag.
Aber gucken wir mal weiter.
Ja, das ist richtig. Da hat er recht. Da hat er recht.
Ja.
Ja, das ist, das ist in der Theorie, der hat, der hat schon komplett recht. Aber wie gesagt, gerade im Heimbereich, das, worauf ich den Hauptfokus legen würde, ist möglichst einfache Maintainability.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig ausgesprochen. Weil dann macht man es nämlich auch. Es hat keinen Sinn, wenn ich das alles super krass komplex, secure aufbaue, aber dann keinen Bock mehr habe, mich darum zu kümmern.
Dann ist es ein bisschen einfacher, aber ich mache regelmäßig.
Ich kümmer mich regelmäßig um Updates und kümmere mich regelmäßig darum. Auf jeden Fall sinnvoller.
Und dementsprechend kann es durchaus sinnvoll sein. Man nimmt einfach ein Standard Ubuntu Image für seine Container, wenn man ab und zu vielleicht sich auch mal reinkonnecten will und was nachgucken als irgendwie einen Alpine Linux oder sowas.
Ich würde halt immer das offizielle Image nehmen und gut ist.
Und das mit diesem Attack Surface. Ja, in der Theorie natürlich alles, was du da drauf hast, kann potenziell Probleme machen.
Aber du.
Bist ja bei einem Container prinzipiell schon mal ein bisschen sicherer unterwegs, erstens wegen der Sandbox drumherum.
Das ist aber nicht der hauptsächliche Punkt.
Aber es ist ja erst mal nur das Exposed, was du explizit auch freischaltest.
Also wenn du einfach ein Container startest, ohne Ports weiterzuleiten, kann dem Container jetzt erst mal nicht so wirklich viel passieren.
Du musst ja erst mal an Ports weiterleiten, dass du überhaupt auf die Anwendung da drauf kommst.
Und die Anwendung hat halt nun mal gewisse Abhängigkeiten.
Ja.
Also.
Er hat schon recht.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob man da so großen Fokus daheim drauf legen muss.
Ich nehme das offizielle Image und fertig ist.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Da hat er recht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich würde nie, ich würde nie Latest nehmen.
Ich würde immer irgendwie sowas hier vornehmen.
Entweder Stable ist auch so.
Ich würde nach Möglichkeit sowas hier nehmen.
Ich würde 120 als Tag nehmen.
Das bedeutet nämlich, ich bekomme Updates.
Security Updates für 1.2.
Also ich bekomme, wenn ich den Tag 120 nehme, bekomme ich 1202 als Pack.
Aber nicht 121 oder oder 2!
Das würde ich machen.
Also habe ich das bei meinen Containern auch gemacht.
Also ich würde einen V Year's Tag nehmen, aber dann inklusive den Patches, also.
Ich würde den übergeordneten Versions Tag nehmen.
Palest besten Problem haben auf der Arbeit auch gerade.
Ja, Doku-Wiki hat überhaupt keine ordentlichen Tags. Ich weiß nicht, was sie so treiben.
Ja, das würde ich nehmen.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich nehmen. Da kriege ich nämlich die Patches für 1.2.1 und es ist sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, das, was bei einem Update kaputt geht, innerhalb des gleichen Releases.
Ich habe bei seinem Setup eh das Gefühl, er macht nichts anderes als Maintenance Rotation.
Okay, geben wir uns.
Da ist was dran.
Das stimmt.
Ja.
Also, wenn man wirklich...
Wenn man wirklich externe Services daheim hosten will, ist das natürlich sinnvoll. Wie gesagt, ich würde prinzipiell keine externen Services bei mir daheim hosten, was mit der Internetanbindung in Deutschland meistens auch gar nicht sinnvoll möglich ist.
Das kann nicht nur die Leistung verbessern, sondern auch die Sicherheit. Du kannst das durch Subnetting oder VLANs machen. Und das erlaubt dir, vertraute Geräte separat zu halten.
Naja, Firewalls haben jetzt erstmal prinzipiell nicht unbedingt was mit Subnetting und VLANs zu tun.
Schon, schon, klar. Also, das spielt damit rein. Aber Firewall ist ja erstmal auf IP-Ebene in der Regel. Also, so Quelle, Ziel und Port. Also, auf IP und... Was ist das über IP?
Oh, Osi-Modell, Leute. Transportschicht und... Bei euch ist das noch nicht so lang her.
Ja.
Sicherungsschicht und Transportschicht, kann das sein? Ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mal genau zusammen. Also, das müsste dann Layer 3 und 4 sein? Ey, keine Ahnung, scheiß drauf, Osi-Modell, Alter.
Also, das ist ja in der Regel das, wo Firewalls aktiv sind.
Ähm...
Subnetting insofern, dass die über die Firewall gehen müssen erstmal, ist natürlich...
...sinnvoll, weil du von einem Netz nicht ins andere kommst. Aber ansonsten haben Subnetz und VLANs mit Firewalls erstmal nicht so viel zu tun.
Die DDoS-Rakete.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt. Da hat er natürlich recht.
Da hat er natürlich recht. Deswegen hat man normalerweise, wenn man sowas macht, eine DMZ vorne, bevor es dann intern...
Aber das ist auch der Grund, warum ich sowas schlicht und ergreifend einfach nicht intern hosten würde.
Oh ja, das stimmt. Da gebe ich ihm recht.
Das ist das China...
Das ist das China-Chinesen-Kekomrit-WLAN daneben.
Hier.
Das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll an der Stelle.
Die ganzen IoT-Geschichten, die sollten unbedingt in ein eigenes WLAN, WLAN und Firewall regeln dazwischen. Unbedingt. Ja.
Da muss ich halt auch mal überlegen.
Ähm...
Mittlerweile gibt es so viele smarte Geräte daheim.
Von der Küchenmaschine bis zum Wäschetrockner, von irgendwelchen Lichtschaltern bis Lampen an der Decke.
Und dass die Geräte smart sind in dem Sinn, ist eigentlich nicht das Problem.
Ja, sind das Z-Wave, Zigbee-Geräte oder sonst was, ist das kein Ding. Das stimmt schon, was der Chat gerade schreibt.
Problematisch sind IoT-Geräte, die einen vollwertigen Netzwerk-Stack haben.
Also IP, TCP und alles mögliche, die halt über WLAN ins Internet gehen.
Ja.
Das ist eine super teuer bezahlte Business-Enterprise-Lösung. Jetzt könnt ihr euch mal überlegen, was passieren kann und wenn man im Internet ein bisschen rumguckt, sind ja auch schon öfters mal Sachen passiert in dieser Richtung, wenn zum Beispiel IoT-Geräte sich Firmware-Updates ziehen, die dann halt nicht nur IoT'en, sondern auch Teil von irgendeinem Botnetz dann neuerdings sind oder was auch immer treiben.
Und das kann natürlich bei WLAN-Geräten passieren.
Schon gar nicht ins Internet raus.
Und ich glaube, niemand möchte, dass der Lichtschalter, den man hat, demnächst beteiligt ist an irgendeinem DDoS-Angriff.
So bescheuert das klingt, im Jahr 2022 ist das durchaus eine äußerst realistische Möglichkeit, dass euer Lichtschalter beim nächsten DDoS-Botnetz-Angriff mitmacht.
Lichtschalter goes brrrr, genau.
Brrt.
Skrrra.
Pa-pa-pa-pa-pa.
Macht er dann.
Paintschamp.
Mitigate risk.
And now on to external network.
This is where the real fun begins.
This is how users and devices enter your network.
And for obvious reasons, you want to be sure that only the ports you need to be forwarded are forwarded to the proper device.
Das ist richtig.
In most cases, you'll be hosting something like a website.
Wie nennt man dieses Firewall-Modell hier eigentlich?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall keine dreibeinige Firewall mehr.
Und es ist auch keine klassische 2-2-Layer-DMZ.
Was ist denn das?
Fällt mir nichts dazu ein gerade, was das für ein Firewall-Modell ist.
Und wenn das der Fall ist, willst du sicher sein, dass es nur das 4-4-3-Modell für HTTPS zu dem Server geht, das es runnt.
Das Hydra-Modell.
Du willst keine weiteren Ports öffnen.
Das ist da der Recht, da der Recht, ja.
Du willst das fortwählen zu einer Reverse-Proxy, die vor deiner Webseite sitzt.
Das ist auch richtig.
Das ist auch durchaus richtig.
Das ist halt krasser Overkill für die meisten Leute daheim.
Aber ja, ich würde, wenn ich, sagen wir mal noch, für den Fall der Fälle, dass ich wirklich, ich hab doch hier das Video von mir.
Ich zeig das mal kurz.
Ich hab doch da ein Bild von meinem Netzwerk drin.
Für den Fall der Fälle, dass ich mal wirklich auf die Idee kommen würde, sagen wir mal, ich würde mir eine Webseite machen.
Angenommen, ich möchte mich irgendwie...
Ich würde mich dazu bewerben und würde irgendwie so eine Portfolio-Webseite machen oder so.
Und die hoste ich selbst.
Was ich nicht machen würde, aber nur mal für den Fall der Fälle.
Hier hab ich ein Bildchen von meinem Netzwerk.
Was ich dann machen würde, ist folgendes.
Ich nehme mir beispielsweise einen Raspberry Pi.
Und würde den hier dran anschließen.
Quasi das Netz zwischen Fritzbox und meinem Router-Firewall.
Hier würde dann ein Raspberry Pi dran kommen.
Und...
Der bekommt dann halt einen Nginx drauf oder was auch immer, irgendeine Reverse-Proxy.
Und dann würde ich wahrscheinlich meine Web-Anwendung dahinter laufen lassen.
Wenn es einfach nur eine Webseite ist, wird die direkt vom Nginx ausgeliefert, ohne irgendwie Reverse-Proxy oder sonst was.
Der Vorteil ist, dann kann ich auch gleich Zertifikatsmanagement und sonst was drüber machen.
Alles gut.
So würde ich es wahrscheinlich benutzen, ja.
Aber ansonsten, wenn ich irgendwie sowas wie Nextcloud hätte.
Es gibt ja Leute, die wollen Nextcloud extern aufrufbar machen.
Ich würde immer einen Reverse-Proxy davor stellen, der sich nicht nur um Zertifikate kümmert, sondern auch um Authentifizierung, weil ich traue Nextcloud kein Stück.
Also ich meine nicht damit, dass die was einbauen absichtlich, sondern einfach nur, dass sie es nicht richtig auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ja, äh, Reverse-Ports, ja natürlich.
Ich benutze auch intern einen Reverse-Proxy, allein schon für Zertifikatshandling.
Ich habe hier für alle internen Services gültige Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate.
Und das geht nur, wenn es...
Wenn es über einen Reverse-Proxy geht.
Ansonsten müsste sich ja jeder Dienst selbst um Zertifikate kümmern.
Das ist ja unsinnig.
Ups, wollte ich gar nicht abspielen.
Ist gar nicht mal ein Video.
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich würde Nextcloud im Leben nicht öffentlich ins Internet stellen, aber es gibt ja Leute, die wollen das.
Und wenn überhaupt, dann mit VPN.
Aber wenn man das wirklich, wirklich will, dann nur mit einem Reverse-Proxy davor.
Warum nicht?
Naja, weil du da ziemlich private Daten drauf liegen hast und alles.
Wo du jemandem die Möglichkeit gibst, direkt vom Internet drauf zu connecten, hast du halt potenziell ein Problem.
Auch wenn es gerade keine bekannten Sicherheitslücke gibt, aber du hast immer, sagen wir mal, die Tür auf.
Gibt es Sicherheitslücken, kann man es halt ausnutzen, weil der Port ist halt auf.
Wenn du ein VPN dazwischen hast, dann kann keiner drauf von außen, außer du mit VPN-Einwahl.
Und wenn du gar nichts offen hast, können die halt gar nichts machen.
Sobald du den Port weiterleitest, sobald du quasi von außen...
Auf diesen Dienst draufkommst, ist der Dienst potenziell verwundbar, wenn es Probleme gibt.
Das muss einem halt klar sein.
Deswegen würde ich mindestens den Reverse-Proxy davor stellen.
Aber ich würde es eigentlich nach Möglichkeit nie nach außen aufmachen.
Was?
Warum genau sollte ich an der Stelle einen Cloudflare Reverse-Proxy verwenden?
Hä?
Das ist doch schon außen quasi.
Jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Ach so.
Jetzt weiß ich, was er meint.
Der meint das Gleiche, wo der Preisschamp auch drüber gelaufen ist.
Nur halt dann auf dem Hetzner-Server und nicht über...
Der meint diese Basic Cloudflare DDoS Protection.
Ja, das kann man machen.
Ja.
Naja, das stimmt nicht wirklich.
Die Cloud verleitet das ja einfach nur weiter.
Also wenn dein Service dahinter verwundert wird, dann ist das nicht so einfach.
Also wenn dein Service dahinter verwundbar ist, über irgendwie SQL-Injection, was auch immer,
dann macht Cloudflare nichts dagegen.
Heißt nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung von den Paid-Tiers bei Cloudflare.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, Cloudflare hat irgendeinen Service,
der DNS, der der SQL-Injection-Versuch vielleicht sogar erkennt.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Aber zumindest im Free-Tier ist da nichts.
Ja.
Man sollte eine Sache noch sagen.
Cloudflare kann den Traffic lesen.
Also, das muss einem auch klar sein.
Der Inhalt ist nicht verschlüsselt.
Der Inhalt ist verschlüsselt zwischen deinem User und Cloudflare.
Nicht zwischen dir und dem User.
Cloudflare ist quasi der Endpunkt, wenn du ein User und ein User zusammen hast.
wenn du es so willst. Also wenn du es so machst,
wie die hier, so wie er das macht,
dass Cloudflare das weiterleitet.
Du kannst diese Verbindung hier auch
verschlüsselt haben zwischen Cloudflare und dir,
aber Cloudflare kann da reingucken.
Hier hört die
SSL-Verbindung auf,
wenn du es so machst.
Weil hier muss ja auch das Zertifikat liegen,
was ausgeliefert wird an den Client.
Cloudflare kann das lesen, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich kenne mich mit Cloudflare
überhaupt nicht gut aus. Es gibt bestimmt
Möglichkeiten, das anders zu machen.
Aber da kannst du einige Services
von Cloudflare da nicht verwenden.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich hab Cloudflare
noch nie mehr als das Free Tier verwendet.
Ja, das stimmt.
Da kriegst du einen Captcha.
Dann kriegt jeder,
dann kriegt aber jeder einen Captcha,
auch normale User.
Wie bekommst du Let's Encrypt-Sorts
für internes Zeug? Braucht man da nicht
für eine eigene Domäne?
Nein, doch. Ich hab eine eigene Domäne.
Die eigene Domäne,
die zeigt auf den Cloudflare-DNS,
also die gehen über den Cloudflare-DNS,
wird die aufgelöst. Also im Prinzip wird gar nichts
aufgelöst, aber der Cloudflare-DNS ist dafür zuständig.
Und ich hab
dann intern
entweder Traffic oder Nginx,
die benutzen dann
die DNS-Challenge
von Let's Encrypt
und gehen über die Cloudflare-API
an den DNS von
Cloudflare.
Hinterlegen dort die Secrets für Let's Encrypt.
Let's Encrypt macht DNS-Challenge
und es funktioniert.
Also die Server müssen nicht von außen erreichbar sein.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, das muss ich mir kurz angucken.
Hab ich da angesehn-
Ne halbe Million Sachen die letzten 30 Tage.
Das ist nicht wirklich viel.
Also dass es jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise so geht.
Art und Weise leistungstechnisch Probleme machen würde, aber immerhin werden seine Sachen aufgerufen.
Ja, das ist der mit dem Industrie-Level-Homelab, genau.
Ey, der Preisschamp hatte mehr, aber der Preisschamp ist Geschichte.
Ich glaube der Cloudflare hatte 3 Millionen Aufrufe oder so insgesamt.
Ja, das funktioniert, aber natürlich kann
man einstellen.
Kann man blocken, das ist halt nur Absender-IP Cloudflare und sowas, das funktioniert.
In der Home Assistant App zeige ich das gar nicht an, Home Assistant und WebRTC funktionieren
nicht gescheit zusammen.
Ne, nicht WebRTC, das war wieder was anderes.
Ähm.
Die Zip-App, die wir hatten, ja, ja, ne, ne, ne, hat mit Home Assistant, da hat das überhaupt
nichts zu tun.
Ne, ne, äh, ich hab auf, auf dem Handy hab ich eine Zip-App von irgendwas Softphone oder
so.
Das hat mir der Chat mal empfohlen, das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Äh, irgendwas mit Softphone, weiß gar nicht, wie der Kram heißt.
Äh, das ist eine App, die muss man, muss man einmalig bezahlen.
Dass man auch, äh, Push-Notifications für Anrufe und sowas, ne, ne, nicht Zäuper, nicht
Zäuper.
Ähm, Softphone, irgendwas, Softphone heißt das, so, so ein graues Logo, weiß gar nicht,
wie das heißt.
Das ist eine Zip-App, da hab ich bezahlt, dass ich Push-Notifications für Anrufe bekomme.
Und dann ruft mich das Ding über Zip an und dann muss ich das abnehmen, ich sehe dann
anhand der Nummer, dass es die Türklingel ist.
Und dann nehme ich ab und dann bekomme ich ein Video von, von der Tür, ja.
Aber, die Sache ist die, wir haben es ja im Stream ausprobiert, ich kann die Tür-Gegensprechanlage
mit einer extra Kamera kombinieren, das funktioniert.
Ich kann dann sogar mit dem Handy, mit dem Typ reden, aber das habe ich nie so fertig
programmiert, weil ich will gar nicht mit dem Typen reden, an der Gegensprechanlage.
Habe ich mir nämlich überlegt, weil ich hatte bisher noch nicht einmal die Situation, dass
ich unterwegs war.
Jemand geklingelt hat und ich will mit dem reden, weil was soll ich denen sagen?
Ja, hallo, Sie sind gerade an meiner Klingel, aber ich bin eigentlich gar nicht da.
Ja, das ist ja schwachsinnig.
Aber ich bekomme einen Anruf und kann den annehmen und bekomme dann ein Bild von einer
Kamera angezeigt, die auf die Tür, also die auf die Tür gerichtet ist, dass ich sehe,
wer vor der Tür steht.
Also ich sehe dann zum Beispiel, ah, guck mal, es ist DHL oder so.
Ja.
Ja, aber ich zeige das nicht in der Home Assistant App an.
Die Home Assistant App kannst du komplett vergessen für
Kameras und Low Latency Video, auch WebRTC geht nicht richtig mit der Home Assistant App,
das ist ziemlicher Müll.
Ja, so ist das halt.
Wir haben mal ein Video dazu gemacht, Traffic mit Cloudflare im Stream, müssen wir mal
im Archiv gucken.
Meine Host – die Dienste habe ich zum größten Teil bei Hetzna laufen.
Ja, das würde auch funktionieren.
Ja.
Ein Video-Feed.
Aber ja, ein Bild mit einer Push-Notification würde auch reichen.
Wobei man sagen muss, Push-Notification auf Apple-Gerät ist auch wieder so ein Ding.
Da brauchst du irgendeine Paid-App, so was wie Push-Over oder sowas.
Weil Apple und Push ist, ja, Pantschamp, wie viel ist bei Apple.
Wie funktioniert das genau mit der Haustür-Klingel?
Oh, da haben wir auch ein Video drüber, äh, einen Stream drüber gemacht.
Da habe ich das erzählt, aber so ganz grob, da hängt kein Micro-Controller dran.
Das ist eine Klingel und ich habe auf Ebay, also das ist eine Siedle-Tür-Klingel-Anlage.
Das ist so schwarze Magie, wie das intern alles funktioniert.
Ich habe auf Ebay ein Gerät von denen gekauft, was normalerweise 500 Euro kostet oder so.
So irgendwie 60 Euro.
Das erkennt das Klingeln und kann es über analoges Telefon weiterleiten.
Und ich habe dann ein...
...analoges Telefon-zudeckt-Konverter dran.
Ich habe das doch, ich habe das auf Twitter gepostet, kann ich dir zeigen.
Analoges Telefon-zudeckt-Konverter.
Mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Und dann klingeln bei mir daheim die Telefone.
Dort kann ich dann auch mit, also ich kann an ein normales Telefon bei mir daheim gehen und mit dem Typ an der Tür reden.
Das funktioniert.
Und dann habe ich ein .NET-Programm, was sich per ZIP an meiner Fritzbox anmeldet und erkennt,
...
...wenn das klingelt, wenn die Telefonnummer klingelt, für die Tür und das dann weiterleitet, als extra Anruf an mein Handy.
Das ist ZIP, ZIP, Sorcery haben wir dafür verwendet, glaube, das Programm, also die Library, um das zu basteln.
Und wenn ich an meinem Handy annehme, dann nimmt das den Stream, den Stream von meiner Kamera und...
...packt das an.
Packt den zusammen mit dem VoIP-Call und schickt ihn ans Handy.
Das konnte man alles, es war relativ easy, mit ZIP-Sorcery zu machen.
Sind Weiterleitungen ans Handy nicht relativ teuer?
Denn was heißt Weiterleitungen ans Handy?
Das ist ja keine Weiterleitung in dem Sinn.
Es macht halt einfach einen Call, einen VoIP-Call aufs Handy.
Das kostet ja nichts.
Das geht ja übers Internet.
Das ist ja keine richtig echte, es geht ja nicht über Mobilfunk, es geht ja über die ZIP.
Über die ZIP.
ZIP-App auf dem Handy.
So, ich habe irgendwo auch ein Bild davon, hier, guckt es euch mal an.
Gefährliche, gefährliche Katze hier.
Wie wird das Bild von der Cam gehandelt?
Wir haben ein Video, also wir haben das in einem Stream zusammengebaut.
Ich kriege das aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen.
Wie gesagt, wir haben ZIP-Sorcery genommen.
Dann per RTSP den Kamerastream abgefragt.
Dort die H2, also den H264-encodeten Stream rausgeholt.
Und auf der anderen Seite pipen wir den in den ZIP.
ZIP-Call.
Das war relativ, es war viel einfacher, als ich gedacht habe.
Ja, hier ist auch irgendwie ein Beispiel, für wie man ein Video-Call macht.
Es war, müssen wir mal eher Archiv, gucken wir mal, Archiv.
Tür.
Tür, Klingel, Audio, hier, das da.
Da ist doch das Stream.
Ich habe sogar mal so ein Pfeifert-Paint-Diagramm gemalt.
Ja, Agent, Call.
Und das ist das Programm, mit dem wir es getestet haben, ob der Call ankommt.
Ja.
Es hat funktioniert und es war deutlich einfacher, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
So, ich gucke mal, ob ich das Bild finde.
Muss noch ein bisschen zurückscrollen.
Ist schon ein bisschen her, aber so ewig auch noch nicht.
Habe ich ein Bild vom Testaufbau gepostet.
Äußerst spannend, was da in der Dusche abgeht.
Bild vom Testaufbau gepostet.
Ich hoffe, ich erkenne es beim drüber scrollen.
Wo die Sachen noch hier oben an der Türklingel an der Wand hängen.
Ach ja, by the way.
Mich hat irgendwann so ein China-Shop angehört.
Und hat mir dann geschrieben, ob ich nicht hier für Werbung machen will.
Und das ist das Original-Bild aus der Mail gewesen.
Alles klar, dafür möchte ich garantiert Werbung machen.
So, Bahnflame.
Hier.
Nee.
Das ist die Katze auf der Treppe.
Wo ist das denn?
Ist das schon so lang her?
Viele haben ihn, wissen es aber nicht.
Oh Mann.
Wo ist das denn?
Wo habe ich es denn gepostet?
Ist das schon so lang her?
Das ist übrigens die Kamera am Hoftor.
Hier.
Das war der Testaufbau, wo ich ihn angeschlossen habe, oben an meiner Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
Abenteuerlich, abenteuerlich.
Ja.
Also, das sind die zwei Drähte von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
Das ist das, was ich im Keller auch habe.
Ich meine, mittlerweile liegt das alles unten im Keller und hängt nicht mehr bei mir an der Wand.
Das sind die zwei Drähte von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
Das ist das, was ich im Keller auch habe. Ich meine, mittlerweile liegt das alles unten im Keller und hängt nicht mehr bei mir an der Wand.
Tür klingeln, einen
Analog-Telefonanruf machen kann.
Dann geht der Analog-Telefonanruf
hier über dieses Kabel
da, über dieses Kabel
an eine
Analog-Telefon
zu DECT-Station
und der geht dann per DECT
an die Fritzbox.
Das ist relativ simpel. Du brauchst zwei Geräte
dafür.
Der Rest, der da liegt, ist nur Stromversorgung
beziehungsweise
Kartons auf
Kartons, damit es nicht runterfällt.
Es ist simpel. Es sind zwei Geräte,
die du dafür brauchst. Du brauchst das da und das da.
Der Rest ist einfach nur optisch
nicht so hübsch.
KQA-Setup, ja.
Aber mittlerweile ist das natürlich nicht mehr hier dran,
sondern liegt unten im Keller.
Alles klar. So, jetzt werden wir schnell
das Video fertig gucken, dass das hier noch irgendwie...
Nein, Cloudflare
juckt mich nicht weiter.
Cloudflare Firewall-Droos-ID.
Nein, wir brauchen kein
Intrusion Detection Prevention System
Internal Reverse Proxy
Auth Proxy
Scheiß drauf, komm, ist egal. Weg damit.
Genug geguckt jetzt.
Es hat schon wahren Kern gehabt,
was er gesagt hat. Das ist natürlich wieder absolut
Overkill gewesen. Gibt es dafür...
Das Setup ist doch einfach.
Du brauchst zwei Geräte.
Du brauchst vom Hersteller ein Gerät,
was dafür gemacht ist,
eben Klingel zu
analogem Telefonsignal
umzuwandeln. Entweder
steckst du das hier direkt in deine Fritzbox
und es funktioniert einfach,
wenn du das kannst, weil das Kabel
nah genug dran ist. Oder du brauchst
was, was Analog-Telefon zu Deck macht.
Du brauchst das Gerät und das Gerät.
Das ist ja nicht schwierig.
Ich meine, guck mal, du musst
ein Kabel einstecken, du musst zwei Kabel
einstecken. Das war's.
Du musst zwei Geräte zusammenstöpseln.
Oder du hast eine Klingel, die direkt
SIP kann. Boip. Ja, das geht
natürlich auch. Und
das Ding habe ich bei Ebay
gekauft, weil das kostet neu irgendwie
450 Euro direkt vom Hersteller.
Und bei Ebay hat es irgendwie
78 oder so
gekostet. Und du brauchst
dafür übrigens auch keinen Elektriker
beziehungsweise Angst zu haben, dass du dir was
tust, weil die Spannung
hier drauf ist maximal
glaube ich 30 Volt.
Also da passiert dir nichts.
Bei allem anderen wäre ich vorsichtig.
Die Bahn hat es
verbockt.
Okay.
Ich will den Sound ausmachen.
Alter, das ist
du kannst doch nicht erwarten, dass
die Leute da folgen jetzt.
Mir fällt es echt schwer,
das jetzt vernünftig ohne
Lachen auszudrücken.
Es wurde
verbockt. Wir sind
jetzt hier auf dem Weg nach Hamburg.
Oh scheiße, Alter.
Das ist ja mal voll
für den Arsch.
Wir sind jetzt wirklich auf dem Weg.
Nach Hamburg. Die Verkehrsleitung
ist informiert. Es wissen alle nötigen
Stellen Bescheid.
Ich warte jetzt selbst auf
Informationen, wie es weitergeht.
Meine persönliche
Vermutung ist, dass wir mit
diesem Zug hier bis Hamburg-Harburg
fahren.
Moment, Moment.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo Bremen liegt.
Ich weiß aber ziemlich gut, wo Hamburg liegt.
Mal kurz gucken.
Map Bremen.
Das ist doch ein ganzes Stück weg, oder?
Also Bremen.
Naja, es geht doch eigentlich.
Das ist eine Stunde. Okay, okay, ey.
Ich meine, immerhin.
Das ist ja nicht...
Es hätte krasser sein können.
Aber du bist ja locker mal 2-3 Stunden...
Eher 3 Stunden zu spät.
Umgehend an Sie bezüglich
noch um die Uhr.
Schon die Information, dieser Zug hier
wurde fehlgeleitet. Wir sind jetzt hier
auf der Strecke Richtung Hamburg
anstatt Richtung Bremen.
Noch auf Englisch, please.
Bremen, wirklich angekommen.
Schätzung wird es nach
14 Uhr sein.
Wie gesagt, sobald mir
Informationen zugestellt werden, meine Damen und Herren,
gebe ich die so umgehend weiter.
Ich kann mich hier nur an dieser Stelle
für die Firma entschuldigen.
Ja, also
der Zugbegleiter hat
mein Mitgefühl auch an der Stelle.
Der kann ja dafür gar nichts.
Und der versucht ja wirklich sein Bestes, das auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Der ganze Laden ist halt einfach kompletter Fail.
Also,
ich habe mich oft genug dazu ausgelassen.
Geil.
Oh Mann.
Das ist wirklich Hardcore Fail.
Die Aussage fand ich auch geil.
Mir fällt es echt schwer, das jetzt ohne Lachen
vernünftig auszudrücken.
Naja gut.
Machst du nix, ne?
Mach noch die Videobeschreibung auf.
Background.
Das lese ich jetzt aber nicht.
Ach, hier ist die...
Ernsthaft?
Der hat einfach die komplette,
Fahrt gefilmt, oder was?
Okay, da musst du schon Hardcore-Bahn-Enthusiast sein.
W...
Bäh.
Okay.
Da musst du schon Hardcore-Bahn-Enthusiast sein,
wenn du dir
das anguckst.
I-I-C-E-S-M-A.
Ja, wirklich.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es bestimmt...
Doch, ohne Scheiß, ich kann es mir vorstellen,
das ist bestimmt sehr beruhigend.
Das ist bestimmt sehr beruhigend.
Das kann man sich bestimmt wunderbar zum Schlafen angucken.
Zum Schlafen angucken.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Darf er in der Bahn überhaupt Filme aus dem Fernsehen...
Warum nicht?
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Dummes Verb, danke schön für den Sub.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
What is Nam?
Story of Twitch Anti-Weep-Emote.
Oh, den Test vom Staubsauger-Roboter,
den wollte ich mir tatsächlich angucken,
weil ich mir immer noch überlege,
ob ich mir nicht diesen Staubsauger-Roboter kaufe.
Wir gucken uns jetzt den Test für den Staubsauger-Roboter an.
Ich bin immer noch am überlegen,
ob ich mir nicht den Staubsauger-Roboter kaufe.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Nachdem ich in der Vergangenheit bereits den Dreamy L10 Pro
und auch den D9 getestet habe,
kommt dieses Mal der Z10 Pro dran.
Was ist das Besondere?
Wir haben eine Obstacle-Avoidance
und natürlich auch eine Absorbstation mit dabei.
Obstacle-Avoidance heißt, er hat eine Kamera?
Ich will keinen Staubsauger-Roboter mit Kamera haben.
Ist er kompatibel, weil er To-Do?
Ja, ist er.
Deswegen habe ich es mir schon überlegt,
ob ich ihn mir kaufen kann.
Ich kaufe.
Das ist der aktuell empfohlene Roboter dafür.
Und das Ganze zu einem Preis von ungefähr 500 Euro.
Was das Gerät leistet,
schauen wir uns in den folgenden Minuten gemeinsam an.
An der Stelle möchte ich mich auch recht herzlich bei Dreamy bedanken.
Die haben nämlich freundlich für das Gerät zum Test zu verfügen gestellt.
Ich will aber keinen mit Kamera.
Solange der nur Radar gedöhnt ist,
obendrauf hat es ja alles okay.
Wenn du über Saugroboter wissen willst,
die Geräte miteinander vergleichen möchtest,
dann schau unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Da habe ich den Link zu unserem Blog gesetzt.
Da findest du den Saugroboter-Finder mit 4.
Vielen, vielen Modellen, die wir getestet haben.
Auch noch einige mehr.
Da kannst du alle gegenüberstellen und miteinander vergleichen.
Ich würde sagen, los geht's.
Alter, was ist das für Musik wieder?
Doch, der hat eine Kamera.
Der hat eine Kamera vorne.
Ich will keinen Roboter mit Kamera.
Da können die Chinesen zugucken,
wie er bei mir die Wohnung sauber macht.
Ob sie es wirklich können, keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall das Potenzial dazu da.
0,0 x 35,0 x 9,5.
0,68 cm bei einem Gewicht von 3,17 Kilogramm.
Die Saugleistung beträgt 4000 Pascal,
was in einer maximalen Lautstärke von 64 Dezibel resultiert.
Die Akkukapazität beträgt 5200 mAh,
was für eine Reinigungsdauer von 150 Minuten...
Das sollte reichen.
Das Volumen des Staubbehälters beträgt 400 Milliliter...
Also der Grund, warum ich mir das kaufen möchte,
vielleicht ist, dass es die Absaugstation dabei hat.
...150.
Dazu gibt es natürlich noch die Absaugstation.
Schauen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam die technischen Daten
und auch das mitgelieferte Zubehör des Streamy Z10 Pro an.
Ja, zeig her.
Eigentlich handelt es sich hier eigentlich um einen L10 Pro,
der jetzt eine Absaugstation mit dazu bekommen hat.
Nicht optional.
Das Ganze wird hier nur in einem Bundle verkauft.
Und es ist auch nicht möglich...
Leute, ist auch ganz einfach.
Natürlich kannst du die ins China-Chinesen WLAN stellen
oder sonst was in der Richtung.
Klar, das kannst du machen.
Aber das ist wie vorhin bei der Frage,
Sachen ins Internet stellen oder nicht.
Hat das Gerät gar keine Kamera?
Egal, was du machst, kannst du die kameraschneiden.
Die kann man mit der Kamera nicht benutzen,
weil es gibt keine Kamera.
Das ist das Gleiche wie Sachen ins Internet stellen.
Sind die Dinger nicht im Internet,
musst du dir keine Gedanken machen.
Was nicht da ist, kann nicht kaputt gehen im Internet,
kann nicht Probleme machen.
Das ist wie willig kein Staubsaugerroboter mit Kamera.
Ganz einfach.
Das Lieferzubehör ist wie bei Streamy typisch recht überschaubar.
Wir haben hier lediglich eine kleine Anleitung,
beziehungsweise die Anleitung ist recht dick.
Nur wenn ich was in der App ausstelle,
ist es die offizielle App.
Und da weiß ich auch nicht, was das macht.
Das Beste ist tatsächlich einfach kein Staubsaugerroboter mit Kamera.
Fertig.
Staubsaugstation mit dabei.
Wir sehen hier in der Front die Obstacle Avoidance.
Ich finde das toll, dass man das Obstacle Avoidance nennt anstatt Kamera.
Die Hindernisse im Weg erkennen soll.
Darauf komme ich aber auch gleich im nächsten Thema noch zu sprechen.
Ansonsten haben wir einen Bumper im Laser-Navigationsturm verbaut.
Wir haben die Spot-Clean-Taste, die An-Aus-Taste und die Return-to-Home-Taste.
Auf der Rückseite sehen wir auch eine Wisch-Funktion.
Unter der Klappe haben wir noch einen Mimiliter.
Ja, das hat mein aktueller auch schon, aber die habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Da habe ich gesagt, ist er groß.
Beim L10 Pro ist er ein bisschen größer.
Da ist natürlich hier die Aussparung zum Absaugen nicht vorhanden.
Dementsprechend musste das Ganze hier ein bisschen aufs Volumen gehen.
Gleiches beim Wassertank.
Da ist er auch ein bisschen kleiner als drüben,
weil halt einfach hier ein bisschen was weggeschaut wurde.
Aero, danke für den Zap.
Der Wassertank ist entfernt.
Wir haben hier eine aktive Wisch-Funktion vorhanden.
Ja, brauchen wir nicht.
Er ist elektronisch gesteuert.
Hat meiner auch. Brauchen wir nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe ihn nicht einmal verwendet bisher.
... eingestellt werden.
Aber ansonsten keine vibrierende Wisch-Funktion.
Dementsprechend auch einfach nur ein Lappen, der hinterher gezogen wird.
Bei Ecovacs oder auch bei Roborock zum Beispiel haben wir mittlerweile vibrierende Wischplatten.
Das sieht gut aus.
Das müssen wir dann einfach noch einen Ticken gründlicher machen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bevorzuge vibrierende Lappen.
Schauen wir nochmal nach unten.
Hier sehen wir die beiden Öffnungen.
Dass der Staubbehälter entleert werden kann.
Die Hauptrolle schwimmend gelagert.
Wir haben sechs Absturzsensoren auf der Seite.
Oh ja, das muss bei mir auch so sein, weil der fällt sonst die Treppe runter.
... eine Seitenbürste und natürlich hier die Hauptbürste.
Soviel zum Roboter erstmal selbst.
Werfen wir noch einen kurzen Blick auf die Absaugstation.
Wir haben hier die Absaugstation mit den zwei Öffnungsstutzen an der Front.
Die Ladekontakte hier.
Die Sensorik.
Auf der Unterseite sehen wir auch hier nochmal den Schacht.
Falls es irgendwo verstopfen sollte, können wir das hier erkennen.
Kann man auch aufbauen.
Auf der Rückseite haben wir auch ein Kabelmanagement.
Sodass wir das Ladekabel ein bisschen drum rum kürzen können.
Je nachdem wie es braucht.
Ein riesen Ding ey.
Da passt wenigstens auch ordentlich was rein.
... dimensioniert.
Und auf der Oberseite.
Machen wir das mal auf.
Auch den Staubbehälter ist es auch nur einer.
Wisst ihr, was ich übrigens voll cringe finde?
Sagt jetzt nichts über die Qualität des Videos.
Ich weiß, ich finde es immer blöd, wenn Leute mit Du angesprochen werden im Video.
Es ist jetzt nicht einer.
Ich sage immer Ihr.
Ich sage immer Ihr, weil ich weiß, da sitzen jetzt irgendwie 10.000 Leute und gucken sich das an.
Deswegen sage ich nie Du.
Ich sage immer Ihr.
Da braucht man auch einen Filter, ja klar.
Aber leider, das wäre natürlich cooler, wenn dann im Endeffekt hier sich der Staub drin stapeln würde,
dass man es einfach ausleeren kann.
Nee, nee, nee, so einfach ist das nicht.
Im Prinzip ist es ja ein Sauger für den Sauger.
Also diese Saugstation, also saugt den Staubsauger-Roboter leer.
Ja, so lange habe ich ihn noch nicht getestet.
Roboter, die den Staub bei mir aufsaugen, dementsprechend ist er nicht voll.
So viel zu den Details.
Ich würde sagen, wir kommen zur Navigation.
Thema Navigation ist natürlich besonders spannend, weil die darüber entscheidet, ob der Roboter auch jeden Winkel bei dir in der Wohnung findet.
Die Facebook-Staubsauger-Gruppe.
Das sollte man hier unterscheiden zwischen der eigentlichen Navigation, wie findet sich der Roboter zurecht
und natürlich auch der Hinderniserkennung der Obstacle Avoidance.
Du siehst es gerade schon im Top-Down-Shot bei mir durch den Bones-Bereich hat der Roboter ungefähr 34 Minuten benötigt.
Die Navigation ist wirklich hervorragend.
Er findet wunderbar hier zurecht.
Allerdings sieht er die Hindernisse nicht immer.
Ich musste hier mal eingreifen, habe das kleine Ladekabel und auch die Socken aus dem Roboter wieder rausholen müssen.
Die Schuhe wurden gut erkannt.
Die anderen beiden Hindernisse nicht so gut.
Das ist sehr schade.
Ihr kennt es vielleicht schon aus meinen anderen Videos.
Ich bin da so ein bisschen skeptisch, was die Obstacle Avoidance angeht.
Sowohl bei Roborock als auch bei Ecovacs sind das nice Add-ons wie auch hier.
Allerdings ist es einfach was, worauf wir uns noch nicht zu 100% verlassen können.
Was ich ein bisschen schade finde.
Ah, das Kabel gefressen.
Trotz ist die Navigation wirklich hervorragend.
Er fährt wunderbar um andere Hindernisse, wie zum Beispiel Stuhlbeine oder so drumherum.
Daran gibt es nichts zu meckern.
Aber ihr müsst halt eben aufpassen, wenn es Hindernisse sind, die aufgesaugt werden können.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, also dieses Zimmer und überall, das ist optimal für Staubsaugerroboter.
Das ist glatter Boden.
Die Dinger sind alle so hoch.
Vielleicht ist es auch ein extra Testzimmer von ihm, was er nur dafür verwendet.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist schon ein optimales Verhältnis.
Für so ein Staubsaugerroboter.
Bei mir ist beispielsweise fast überall Teppich.
Das ist dann auch schon mal eine Nummer härter für die Dinger.
Ansonsten Thema Hindernisüberwindung.
Klappt trotzdem gut.
Hat er bei mir hier im Test geschafft.
Das ist ein sehr guter Wert.
Siehst du auch wieder im Saugroboter-Finder.
Da kannst du dir die Werte miteinander mal anschauen und das Ganze vergleichen.
Sodass es hier nichts zu meckern gibt.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, ich wiederhole mich, hat mir die Navigation wirklich sehr gut gefallen.
Und ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt mit der Reinigungsleistung weiter.
Aber warum machen die immer so laut dazwischen?
Schauen wir uns jetzt die Reinigungsleistung des Dreamy Z10 Pro an.
Die Obstacle Avoidance ist natürlich eingeschaltet.
Die maximale Saugleistung habe ich ebenfalls angeschaltet.
Da hat er in ungefähr 3,5 Minuten 80,52 Gramm auf dem Laminat aufgesaugt.
Das ist ein erschreckend schlechtes Ergebnis.
Warum das hier so ist und warum die Bürste hier nicht komplett bis zum Boden gekommen ist,
kann ich an der Stelle nicht sagen.
Schlecht.
Das ist ein bisschen schade.
Auch beim...
Beim L10 Pro damals habe ich schon festgestellt, dass auf dem Laminat die Saugleistung mit nur 91,68 Gramm
auch nicht so gut war, wie ich mir das wünschen würde.
Aber dafür haben die beiden Modelle auf dem Teppich wirklich gut abgeliefert.
Der Z10 Pro hat hier in 3 Minuten 40 71,57 Gramm aufgesaugt.
Das ist ein gutes Ergebnis, kein Spitzenergebnis, aber liegt definitiv über dem Durchschnitt.
An der Stelle auch nochmal der Hinweis auf unseren Saugroboter Finder.
Da kannst du alle Saugleistungsergebnisse gegenüberstellen.
Zum Beispiel den L10 Pro mit dem Z10 Pro und siehst auch da, wo die Unterschiede liegen.
Nur ich kann das.
Ich kann das.
Ihr könnt das nicht.
Redet nur mich an.
Dementsprechend den Link findest du unten in der Beschreibung.
Ich finde das...
Es ist eine Stilfrage.
Ich finde es einfach ein bisschen weirdchamp, wenn man die Leute direkt anredet im Video.
Aber das ist echt eine Geschmacksfrage.
Was passiert, wenn man aus Versehen über das Ding stolpert?
Wahrscheinlich, je nachdem wie man fällt, man fällt wahrscheinlich hin.
Da ist man selber dran schuld.
Ansonsten habe ich ein weiteres kleines Problem entdeckt und zwar bei der Eckenreinigung.
Auch hier wurde wieder die Obstacle Avoidance angeschaltet.
Das hat dafür gesorgt, dass der Roboter nicht perfekt in die Ecke reingefahren ist und hier
nur ein von fünf Maiskörnern aufgesaugt hat.
Das ist eine Symptomatik, die ich auch bei Ecovacs Saugrobotern schon mal festgestellt
hatte.
Ist schon eine Weile her, wurde dort aber rausprogrammiert.
Hier habe ich es allerdings wieder festgestellt.
Ich hoffe oder es kann sein, dass es mit einem Update irgendwie behoben wird.
Was die Videos gesehen haben, wo die Haustür offen steht, eben, er hätte schon das Teil
des Innenhofs und den Gehweg saugt.
Ne, was?
Zeig mal.
Ne.
Normalerweise kannst du ja deswegen Zonen in der App festlegen und das Ding weiß ja
anhand, wo es losfällt, an der Basisstation, wo er ist und dann fährt er normalerweise
aus der Zone auch nicht raus.
Ist mir das eben aufgefallen.
Von daher, die Reinigungsleistung ist okay.
Wie gesagt, auf dem Laminat war das nicht so, wie ich mir das wünschen würde.
Auf dem Teppich allerdings sehr gut.
Nochmal kurz, um auf die Wischleistung zu sprechen zu kommen.
Wir haben eine aktive Wasserzufuhr.
Bedeutet, wir können hier die Wassermenge in der App einstellen.
Allerdings bewegt sich das Tuch nicht, wie wir das von einem Roboter sehen, oder von
den neuen Ecovacs-Modellen her kennen.
Moment, wischt der gerade?
Naja.
Das braucht kein Mensch.
Von daher, ich sag mal, ein feuchtes Nachwischen.
Das braucht wirklich keiner.
Mehr und nicht weniger.
So viel zum Thema Reinigungsleistung, ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns nochmal die App
an.
Alter, diese Lautstärke dazwischen ist der Wahnsinn.
Werfen wir jetzt zum Schluss nochmal einen kurzen Blick in die App, gesteuert wird das
über die Mi Home App.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Sache.
Du siehst hier direkt auf der Startseite, dass auch der Dreamy D9 zum Beispiel...
Gut.
Das würde ich ja nicht verwenden.
Ich würde das Ding eh flashen.
... hier eingebunden ist oder der Roborock S7 in meinem Fall.
Schauen wir uns aber den Dreamy Bot Z10 Pro an.
Über das kleine Fegensymbol kannst du den Roboter direkt...
Das Ding wird bei mir eh geflasht.
... wenn wir einfach das Symbol Sonst anklicken.
Kommen wir hier in das Hauptmenü rein.
Du siehst hier meinen Wohn-Ess-Bereich.
Was ist alles möglich?
Du kannst selbstständig die Räume unterteilen...
Ja gut, die App juckt mich jetzt nicht.
... und auch die Symbolen versehen.
Mein abschließendes Fazit zum Dreamy Z10 Pro fällt ein wenig durchwachsen aus.
Grundsätzlich gefällt mir der Saugroboter wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Wir haben eine Absaugstation mit dabei.
Wir haben die Obstacle Avoidance und wir haben auch eine sehr, sehr gute Saugleistung auf dem Teppich.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist die Saugleistung bei mir im Test auf dem Laminat nicht so hervorragend gewesen...
Das wissen wir schon.
Aber an sich scheint es ganz okay zu sein.
Wie gesagt, auf dem Teppich ist es ein bisschen schade.
Aber dafür umso besser.
Ich glaube, ich bleibe weiterhin bei...
Ich renne einmal im Monat schnell mit dem Staubsauger durch.
Ich habe ja meinen Roborock S5 auch quasi in Rente geschickt.
Der steht halt noch im Wohnzimmer da.
Aber den lasse ich nicht mehr fahren.
Ich flitze da ab und zu mal durch.
Zehn Minuten mit dem Staubsauger ist alles geputzt.
Fertig.
Einmal im Monat, das reicht.
Der Front ist auch schön.
Allerdings kam es hier auch hin und wieder zu Problemen.
Dass eben die Gegenstände, die im Weg herum lagen, aufgesaugt wurden.
Und ich hier nochmal nachträglich einschreiten musste.
Bedeutet also für dich, dass du schon auch darauf Acht geben solltest,
dass deine Wohnung frei von Hindernissen und herumliegenden Gegenständen ist.
Ich finde, der Preis von 530 Euro ist durchaus...
Du bist zurück auf manuell gegangen, ja.
Vor allem mit der Absaugstation dabei.
Da kosten andere Produkte...
Das stimmt. Preis-Leistungs-mäßig mit der Absaugstation ist das Ding wirklich nice.
... doch nochmal 1, 2, 300 Euro wert.
Eluminator, danke für den Sub.
... dass es definitiv ein Roboter ist, den du in die nähere Auswahl ziehen solltest.
Und an der Stelle hoffe ich natürlich, dass dir der Test dabei auch ein wenig helfen konnte.
Auch hier nochmal der Hinweis auf unseren Saugroboter-Finder.
Alle von mir getesteten Saugroboter und viele mehr sind dort eingetragen.
Okay, GG Eats. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Moin Max, ich würde es frech finden, wenn die jetzt 2042 Free2Play machen würden.
Vor nicht mal einem halben Jahr haben Leute viel Geld verdient.
Na gut, aber was sollen sie machen?
Ich halte es für die wahrscheinlichste Richtung, in die Battlefield gehen wird.
Die Spielerzahlen sind mega schlecht.
Es spielt ja kaum noch einer. Portal ist tot.
Was sollen sie machen?
Ich halte das für tatsächlich sinnvoll.
Fast die einzige Möglichkeit, das Spiel zu beleben.
Was sagst du dazu?
Ja, wie gesagt, ist halt so. Shit happens.
Also...
Ja, nicht mal vorbestellen.
Ich meine, ich habe auch sinnlos Geld ausgegeben.
Außerdem lockt das ja Unmengen an Cheatern an.
Ach, da würde ich jetzt erstmal nicht so das Problem sehen.
Cheater haben die Herstellung für Battlefield 2042 Cheats eingestellt.
Kein Witz.
Ist wirklich so.
Die haben gesagt, das Spiel spielt keiner mehr.
Es lohnt sich nicht mehr, dafür Cheats zu entwickeln.
Und das ist wirklich kein Witz.
Cheater-Anbieter haben das geschrieben.
Die haben gesagt, wir stellen die Entwicklung für Battlefield 2042 Cheats ein.
Und wer ein Abo gekauft hat, bekommt stattdessen einen Warzone-Cheat.
Ich denke mir das nicht aus. Das ist kein Witz.
Das wird in ein Warzone-Abo umgewandelt.
Das Spiel interessiert keinen mehr.
Nicht mal mehr die Cheater-Hersteller.
Du weißt, wenn ein Spiel tot ist, wenn sogar die Cheater-Hersteller sagen, es lohnt sich nicht, dafür Cheats zu entwickeln.
Das ist kein Witz, was da läuft.
Das ist der beste DRM.
Dein Spiel ist so schlecht, das will keiner kopieren.
Noch nicht mal Sicherheitskopien anfertigen.
Wie man das ja in diesen Kreisen nennt.
So.
Was hat man sonst noch schönes zu bieten?
Dieser Sensor ist zweimal so gut wie der Rest.
Ah.
Welcher Sensor?
Best Door & Window Sensor ist vom Aqara.
Da habe ich sogar welche da.
Xiaomi Aqara.
Habe ich welche am Start hier.
Zigbee-Sensoren sind das.
Die sind tatsächlich sehr nice.
Ich habe so eine Mischung aus Z-Wave und Aqara-Sensoren für die Fenster und Türen.
Ich habe ja beides.
Bei mir ist eh total übertrieben.
Ich habe Zigbee-Geräte.
Ich habe Z-Wave-Geräte.
Ich habe Wifi-Geräte.
Ich habe noch alte 433 MHz Funk-Geräte.
Ich habe Bluetooth-Geräte.
Das ist alles Elektro-Smog.
Für irgendeinen, der da Probleme mit hat, der sich einredet.
Elektro-Smog ist schlecht.
Der dürfte bei mir nicht ins Haus.
Der rennt hier schreiend wieder raus.
Gucken wir uns das mal kurz an.
Ich will mal kurz gucken, ob es wirklich um meinen...
Geht nur 6 Minuten, ob es wirklich um meinen Aqara-Sensor geht.
5G.
Fuck.
Das habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
5G-Strahlung ist ja auch noch am Start.
Und wir haben...
Wir haben auch irgendwo in der Nähe...
Äh...
Also die ganze Ecke weiter weg.
Aber sagen wir mal grob in der Nähe...
Ähm...
Sogar Windkraftanlagen.
Der Infraschall davon.
Was meint ihr hier?
Der killt euch ja auch.
Alles ist...
Dann ist es vorbei.
5G-Infraschall.
Elektro-Smog.
Bluetooth.
Wifi.
2,4.
5 GHz Wifi.
ZigBee Z-Wave.
Das ist vorbei.
Du wirst ja quasi permanent durchlöchert von Elektro-Smog.
Ich lebe immer noch.
Ja.
Und ich bin auch noch geimpft.
Außer, dass mir die Antenne aus dem Arm gewachsen ist, ist ja nichts passiert.
This thing is called a contact sensor.
Sometimes called a door and window sensor.
Even though I think that's pretty close minded.
The problem is with so many...
Und der Bluetooth-Smog von der Corona-App, der kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Sollte man den da schließen, muss man sich auf den Markt überlegen, welchen man sich
kaufen soll.
Today on the Hookup habe ich 14 verschiedene Sensor von 13 verschiedenen Branden und ich
will euch zeigen, warum ich nach 4 Monaten rigorösen Tests ziemlich sicher bin, dass
diese Sensor von ACARA die Anlage ist, die man kaufen sollte.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Und die ganze Sonnenstrahlung und so was.
Ja, deswegen gehe ich ja auch nicht raus.
Ganz einfach.
Sind all diese Sensoren die gleichen?
Definitiv nicht.
Alter, dieser Sensor sieht ja mal richtig oldschool aus.
Ich glaube, der ist nicht so gut.
richtig oldschool aus mit kabel und so was das dahinter ist der aquara sensor
würde ich sagen von der optik her
guck mal es gibt lora sensoren hätte ich gar nicht gedacht dass es so er in in
the wild so zu finden ist cpc bluetooth wifi lora lora sachen habe ich ja auch
noch kommt ja auch noch dabei das ist dann was 800 833 megahertz oder
sowas 817 megahertz was die frequenz irgendwas 800 noch was was er was
sensoren deine sensoren in dem fall ist das ein ein teil das machst du an tür
rahmen und ein teil das machst du an die tür und dann erkennt das gibt es dann
auch los wir haben sogar schon los gemacht und da ist dann ein magnet drin
und irgendein ried switch oder sowas 868 megahertz
der erkennt dann wenn es geschlossen ist und die tür offen oder kann eine
nachricht schicken über das jeweilige protokoll an die heimautomatisierung und
sagt da fenster auf tür auf da kann man dann zum beispiel im dashboard sehen
bevor man raus geht aha ich habe vergessen oben im bad das fenster zu zu
machen es kann ja auch wenn es erkennt dass du weg gehst aus dem haus eine push
notification schicken sein magst wiederum drehen fenster im bad oben ist
noch auf oder es kann auch die heizung runter regeln wenn das fenster aufgeht
und solche dinge ist eigentlich ganz praktisch
der channel von ihm ist wirklich gut wer sich für so heimautomatisierungs zeug
erstellt da macht finde ich persönlich die hochwertigsten videos die es gibt in
dieser richtung oder beschäftigt sich auch immer damit und der typ übertreibt
teilweise richtig krass nummer so als beispiel der hat denn wie der hat holly
der hat halloween beleuchtet
und die ist ein wenig übertrieben von seinem haus guck mal das ist die das ist
die halloween beleuchtung an seinem haus es ist ein wenig etwas over the top
könnte man sagen also der der übertreibt es richtig der typ stellt euch mal vor so
sieht es am haus außen aus das ist schon das schon recht übertrieben
zumindest der hat es auch mit musik synchronisiert und so was ist das ist das
ja ja genau genau aber dementsprechend sieht man das setzt sich mit den mit der
thematik auseinander und wenn der was testet habt ihr ja schon gehört 14
monate getestet dem glaube ich das wirklich wenn er wenn er was vorstellt ja
came out either on or near the top if you've never used a contact sensor
here's a quick rundown of what it does inside the case is a battery and a
magnetic switch that turns on when it gets close to a magnet and off when it
moves away whenever the switch state changes it sends
positive ability expired in your fantasną
ist es ganz
open
Wenn der Briefkasten dafür geeignet ist, muss man sagen, aus dem Metallbriefkasten rausfunken geht immer schlecht.
Und die Dinger anzubringen am Briefkasten, je nachdem, ist es auch nicht so schön.
Fürs Gartentor, alles möglich. Die sind sehr, sehr praktisch.
Ja, auch für die Garagentür, alles mögliche.
Was macht man, wenn man auszieht? Dann braucht man noch Sensoren, die einen benachrichtigen, falls man vergessen hat, einen Sensor.
Wenn du ausziehst, machst du die Sensoren ab.
Und selbst wenn du einen Sensor vergisst, dein Heimautomatisierungssystem ist ja dann nicht mehr da.
Da passiert gar nichts.
Außer, dass vielleicht noch irgendwo an der Garagentür oder so oder im Gartentor irgendwie was vergessen hast.
Was soll da passieren?
Wie ist die Reichweite? Das kommt auf die Technik an.
Also er hat ja hier am Anfang vorgestellt, Sensoren für ZigBee, Z-Wave, Bluetooth, WiFi, LoRa.
Also, kann man im Prinzip so sagen.
Fangen wir mal an.
WiFi ist die Range am schlechtesten.
WLAN geht vielleicht, keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal, wenn du Glück hast, 50 Meter.
Oder vielleicht 100 Meter bis in den Garten, wenn du es halt direkt am Fenster hast, so ein Access Point oder so.
Sagen wir mal 50 Meter.
Also sagen wir mal so quasi vom Eingang des Hauses bis vielleicht in den Hof auf der anderen Seite.
Aber das ist dann auch schon wirklich Limit.
Ich würde mal sagen, in der Realität sogar noch eine ganze Ecke kürzer.
Also innerhalb des Hauses geht es, aber ansonsten ist es vorbei.
Also WiFi ist von der Entfernung.
Ah, da ist auch noch Bluetooth.
Nee, Bluetooth ist noch schlechter. Ich sehe es ja gerade.
Patrick, danke schön. 31 Monate, Hyper Huge Subscription.
Richtig pfeifert. IQ++++, ja.
Also habe ich gar nicht gesehen, dass da Bluetooth dabei ist.
Ja, also Bluetooth ist von der Entfernung noch schlechter.
Zumal es sich hier um Low Energy Bluetooth handelt.
Da weiß ich nicht, wie weit geht Low Energy Bluetooth 5 Meter oder so.
Der Lachs. Danke.
Der lange Lachs ist auch am Start.
Also.
Also Bluetooth Low Energy ist die mit Abstand kürzeste Variante.
Verbraucht aber auch relativ wenig Strom. Low Energy Bluetooth.
WiFi verbraucht viel Strom und hat eine nicht so krasse Reichweite.
LoRa hat bis zu 2 Kilometern Reichweite.
Aber sehr niedrige Datenübertragung. Ist auch ein bisschen Nische und nicht so verbreitet.
LoRa ist für solche Sensoren eigentlich fast wie gemacht.
Und bei ZigBee und Z-Wave sieht es ein bisschen anders aus.
ZigBee und Z-Wave.
Sind beide von der Idee her relativ ähnlich.
Die Reichweite an sich ist nicht so krass.
Aber das ist ein Mesh-Netzwerk.
Das heißt, man kann es mit WiFi auch machen.
Aber du hast in der Regel keinen Mesh-Punkt irgendwo in der Garage oder so hängen.
Das ist standardmäßig schon Mesh-technisch aufgebaut.
Und jedes Gerät, was du bei ZigBee und Z-Wave an die Stelle...
... in der Direktdose anschließt, fungiert als, sagen wir mal, so eine Art Repeater oder als Note in dem Mesh.
Also ich habe es zum Beispiel so.
Ich habe hier oben an meinem Home-Automation-Server den Z-Wave-Stick und den ZigBee-Stick.
Beide wohlgemerkt an einer USB-Verlängerung.
Weil es immer ganz gut ist, wenn die nicht direkt am Server wegen Störsignalen oder was auch immer.
Es funktioniert auf jeden Fall besser, wenn du eine 1 bis 2 Meter USB-Verlängerung nimmst.
Dann hängst du die Dinger nebenhin.
Also hier oben im Server habe ich die ZigBee- und Z-Wave-Sticks.
Ich habe im Haus verteilt überall Z-Wave-Steckdosen.
Da steckt eine drüben im Wohnzimmer.
Hängt eine unten an der Eingangstür.
Hängt eine im Keller.
Hängt eine hinten im Stall.
Hängt eine.
Und ich habe hinten am Teich im Garten einen Temperatursensor.
Auf dem ich erkenne...
Ich muss gerade mal gucken.
Vielleicht kann ich euch ein Screenshot von zeigen.
Ja, ich mache mal kurz ein Screenshot von Paint.
Das ist der Home Assistant Tab für meinen Garten.
So viel ist da...
So viel ist da nicht.
Das ist der Home Assistant Tab für meinen Garten.
Da gibt es einmal einen Baum.
Der ist gerade nicht verfügbar.
Schalter, Strom an und aus im Stall.
Oder...
Die Temperatur im Teich.
Und der Teich ist gerade 4,5 Grad.
Das war die Wassertemperatur im Teich.
So.
Wurde der Baum gefällt?
Nee.
Das ist LED-Beleuchtung.
Die ist gerade einfach nicht angeschlossen.
So.
Und die Temperatur vom Teich
ist ein Z-Wave-Sensor.
Und dieser Z-Wave-Sensor
schickt seine Daten
von...
Also über das Z-Wave-Mesh.
Ungefähr so.
Der Sensor broadcastet das.
Die Z-Wave-Steckdose
im Stall
empfängt das.
Schickt es weiter.
Die Z-Wave-Steckdose an der Eingangstür
empfängt es.
Schickt es weiter.
Dann landet es bei meiner Steckdose
hier oben im ersten Stock.
Die schickt es weiter.
Und dann empfängt es mein Z-Wave-Stick.
Ja.
Und dann hat sie성.
Und dann entdeckt er
meine Z-Wave-S dunkle
Z-Wave-Streckdose.
Und das ist das
Wichtigste.
Und das ist das Wichtigste.
Und da kann ich sagen
Sie wirft es so.
Wenn immer etwas
aus dem Cinema
kommt,
so schnell wie 20
Brieftauben.
Also das ist für solche Sachen
wirklich nicht schlecht. Also ZigBee und
Z-Wave Sensoren finde ich
für sowas am sinnigsten.
Was ist eigentlich zukünftig
ZigBee oder Z-Wave? Tja,
vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich gesagt Z-Wave,
weil auch die Geräte untereinander zumindest
ein gewisses Maß kompatibel sein müssen, aber
dadurch, dass die ganzen großen
von Philips Hue angefangen
bis Xiaomi, Aquara und
Zeug, dass die mittlerweile alle ZigBee sind.
Ich würde sagen beides.
Ja, aber tendenziell
vom Preis her sind auch die ZigBee-Geräte
besser.
Meta sehe ich noch
gar nicht so wirklich.
Zumal es ja auch teilweise
mir bis heute nicht ganz klar ist, was das
ist. Meta ist das übergeordnete
Thread, ist irgendwie die Kommunikation und
Meta kann auch ZigBee sein, was auch immer.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich benutze das, was es gerade gibt und
solange das andere nicht irgendwelche Wahnsinns-Vorteile
bietet, können die mich alle mal.
Juckt mich nicht.
Oder auch um die andere Frage
zu beantworten hier.
Ja, korrekt.
Das war die Frage auf
womit ich das mache, oder?
Wo steht's denn?
Wo ist denn die Frage dazu?
Radio.
Und wo ist er dann?
Achso, die rechte Uhr.
Wie machst du das mit der Stromversorgung?
Genau, das ist ein IP67-Case.
Ich bin mir
gar nicht sicher, ob ich davon irgendwann mal
ein Foto gepostet habe auf Twitter.
Das ist ein IP67-Case
und da drinnen ist
ein Z-Wave-Sensor
mit
einem
DS...
Heißen die Dinger so?
DS
Temperature...
Temperature-Sensor
DS18B20
so rum.
Ne.
Doch.
Genau.
Nein.
Hier.
So ein Ding hängt bei mir im Fischteich.
Was ist Fischteich?
Könnte ja jeder beliebige Teich sein.
Bei mir ist ein Fischteich.
So ein Sensor hängt da im Fischteich drin.
Angeschlossen an einem Z-Wave-Sensor.
Und der Z-Wave-Sensor funkt.
Der Z-Wave-Sensor selbst steckt
nochmal in einem IP67-Case.
Damit es auch schön
wasserdicht ist.
Und der funkt dann
da vor sich hin.
So habe ich das gemacht.
Genau. Okay.
Gucken wir mal im Video weiter.
Heißt das...
Ach, Jolink.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ring. Ring kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Ganz der proprietäre
Crap da.
Und hier sind fünf
einfache Gründe, warum.
Oder ist günstig.
Das Ding kostet noch nicht immer
sonderlich viel. Das kostet irgendwie sieben Euro
oder so einen Sensor. Guck mal.
Sogar, sogar. Okay, mittlerweile wahrscheinlich teurer.
Aquara-Door-Sensor.
Ja gut, die China-Chinesen
auf Amazon, das ist viel zu teuer.
Guck mal, AliExpress gleich.
Ali. AliExpress.
Komm her.
Schauen wir mal.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ähm.
Aquara.
Door-Sensor.
Ja, so. Vier Stück, 40 Euro.
Es ist teurer geworden.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist auch gar nicht der richtige Sensor.
Das sieht schon besser aus.
Äh, was habe ich da standardmäßig ausgewählt?
5,17.
Was sind das?
Wie viele sind das?
Zehn Stück.
Zehn Euro das Stück.
Nee, nee, Zoll musst du nicht bezahlen.
Die sind...
Die sind schlau, was das angeht.
Die verschicken das einfach nach Spanien oder in die Niederlande und dann ist es eine Sendung innerhalb von...
Ach so, ja doch.
Du musst das theoretisch schon bezahlen, aber du musst nicht Angst haben, dass man im Zoll landet.
Alternativ, wie gesagt, die verschicken das eh über Spanien oder Niederlande und dann ist es eine Sendung von EU nach EU und dann juckt es den Zoll eh nicht mehr.
Kann auch sein, dass es mittlerweile Belgien ist.
Ja, muss man mal nach dem günstigsten angehen.
Wir müssen auf das Angebot gucken.
Aber die kann man empfehlen.
Die gibt's, die gibt's, wenn ich jetzt grade, aber im Angebot definitiv unter Zehn Euro das Stück.
Ich hab meins irgendwie für sechs, sieben Euro gekauft.
Banggood ist auch, ist auch ganz gut Seite dafür diese Dinger zu finden.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht wer auf die Idee gekommen ist die Seite Banggood zu nennen.
Aber so ist es halt.
Aquara.
Dorsensor
Ne
Das ist noch teurer
Warum ist es denn da so teuer
Was hältst du von dem Ikea Zigbee Stuff
Kann man ohne Probleme
Ohne Bedenken
Verwenden
Na egal
Wie viel sind das
Pieces
6 Pieces
Lieferung
Von China
Nach Germany
11. März kommt es an
Okay dauert ein bisschen
Ja aber
Die sind deutlich günstiger
Als CWF Sachen
Deswegen würde ich
Das wahrscheinlich
Darauf setzen
Wenn ich mir heute
Da was Neues kaufen würde
So
Jetzt müssen wir uns
Aber erstmal angucken
Warum
Da
Zeig her
Bist du krank Max
Nein
Ich hab wieder das
Ihr habt mich wieder nicht
Daran erinnert
Dass ich was trinken soll
Leute
Ich muss mehr trinken
Wenn ich streame
Sonst kriege ich
Trauer in den Hals
Der Ikea Sensor
Ist kleiner als
Die meisten der anderen
Sensoren die ich getestet habe
Das ist teilweise
Wegen dem Fakt
Dass er
Eine viel kleineren
Batterie verwendet
Als die anderen
Eine kleine
CR1632
Coins
Aber die Batterie
Ohne Scheiß
Ich hab das Ding ja auch
Schon eine Weile
Die Batterie
Die verliert
Irgendwie keine
Keine
Keine Spannung
Also
Die
Daran messen
Ja immer wie voll
Die Batterie ist
Der Batteriestand
Ist immer irgendwie
Noch 98%
Obwohl das Ding
Hier schon
Halbes Jahr rumhängt
Verglichen mit
Den normalen
CR2032
Und CR2450
Wie in den anderen
Sensoren
Und das macht
Den zweiten Grund
Um den Ikea Sensor
Ein bisschen
Mehr zu verwirklichen
Und das ist
Die Batterie
Ich setze
Ein Test
Ja
Ist echt so
Und öffne
Diese Sensoren
Jede 15 Sekunden
Und ich
Rang den Test
Für
Alter
Five Hat
Test
Der hat es
Fünf Monate
Hat er das
Laufen lassen
High IQ Test
Ja gut
Wifi
Wifi ist auch
Müll
Dafür
Und das ist
Ohne die
Bedeutung
Der signifikante
Rapport
Speed
Delay
Für Wifi
Devices
Aber
Die Rest der Sensoren
Mit Protokollen
Wie Bluetooth
Laura
Zigbee
And Z-Wave
Mehr oder weniger
Performen
Das selbe
Außer
Natürlich
Für den
Ikara Sensor
Welcher
Lastet
Zwei
Mal
So lange
Als der nächste
Beste
Sensor
Und sendet
seine letzte
geschlossene
Botschaft
Nach vier
Monaten
Aus
Kontinuier
Und 870.364
Zyklen
Und um das
etwas
Perspektive
Der Ring
Alarm
Kontakt
Sensor
Ja ich
Hab selbst
Z-Wave
Sensoren
I got
Some cheap
Z-Wave
Sensor
From
AliExpress
And
They last
Till today
Only
At the
Entrance
Store
I had
To switch
Batteries
Guck mal
Ich hab die
Dinger hier
Z-Wave
Neo
Irgendwas
Äh
Door
Sensor
Da hatte ich
Mir mal
Irgendwie
Ein 20er
Pack
Bei
AliExpress
Gekauft
Von diesen
Billig
Dingern
Hier
Und die
Heiß
Z-Wave
Die
Haben
Auch
Ewig
Gehalten
Weil
Einer
Auf
Englisch
Gefragt
Hat
Jetzt
Kannst
Sie
Es
Doch
Im
Chat
Wenn
Das
Ding
Nicht
Bei
Jedem
Open
Close
Reportet
Ist
Es
Natürlich
Müll
Und
Most
Of
The
Time
You're
Going
To
Be
Using
These
Sensors
In
A
Security Security
System
Type
Application
Where
A
False
Alert
Or
Missed
Alert
Could
Lead
To
Some
Serious
Issues
Thankfully
The
Car
Sensor
Also
Finished
At
The
Top
Of
That
Test
Maintaining
Over
99.5%
Accuracy
Over
The
Test
Und
In
Reality
It
Was
Probably
Even
More
Accurate
Than
That
Because
At
One
Point
After
About
600.000
Cycles
When
The
Acara
Was
The
Only
One
Left
My
Drawer
I
Have
A
Jelly
But
Not
Everywhere
Where
I
Would
Have
It
Because
I
Don't
Dare
To
Build
Them
Selbst
Ein
Zu
Bauen
Fourth
Reason
To
Choose
The
Acara
Sensor
Is
Compatibility
The
Chat
Fragt
Wenn
Du
Also
In
Russisch
Fragst
Bekommst
Du
In
Russisch
Ja
Frag
Mal
In
Russisch
Auf
Gehen
Wir
Uns
Gekommen
Das
Sensor
In
The
Acara
Sensor
Is
Work
With
Your
Existing
Zigby
Mesh
So
If
You
Already
Have
A
Strong
Zigby
Network
Then
The
Acara
Sensors
Will
Have
Increased
Range
And
Reliability
As
A
Result
If
You
Don't
Already
Have
A
Home
Automation
Hub
I'd
Highly
Recommend
Getting
An
Acara
Hub
Neither
The
E
One
Nein
Ich
Holme
Garantiert
Keine
Acara
Hub
Ich
Hab
Nen
Konbi
Ein
Stick
Und
Zigby
MQTT
In
Home
Assistant
M2
Or
G2H
Camera
Hubs
Which
Open
Up
Every
Other
Google
Assistant
And
Of
Course
Amazon
Echo
And
That
Brings
Me
To
The
Fifth
Reason
To
Go
With
The
Acara
Sensors
And
That's
Price
The
Acara
Contact
Sensor
Is
Normally
Priced
At
Dollars
And
It
Can
Frequently
Be
Found
On
Sale
For
A
Few
Dollars
Oder
Man
Kauft's
Bei
Ali
Express
Und
Bekommt's
Für
Unter
Euro
Was
Das
Sarix
Eben
Auf
Russisch
Gefragt
Hat
Bedeutet
Übersetzt
Max
Warum
Bist
Du
So
Fünf
Köpfig
Wie
Realisierst
Du
Die
Notifications
Über
Telegram
Nee
Ich
Hab
Kein
Telegram
Also
Push
Notifications
Ich
Hab
Ja
Keine
Push
Notifications
Aber
Wie
Gesagt
Ich
Hab
Diesen
Klingel
Anruf
Aber
Ich
Hab
Mal
Ein
Bisschen
Experimentiert
Und
Dann
Hab
Ich
Sober
Push
Auf
Over
Gemacht
Oder
Was
Push
Bullet
Ich
Glaub
Push
Over
Was
Muss
Man
Einmal
Muss
Man
Einmal
Bezahlen
Pro
Device
Aber
Dann
Funktioniert
Aquara
Kaufen
Alles
Klar
Die
Home Assistant
Companion
App
Funktioniert
Nur
Bedingt
Mit
Notifications
Wenn
Du
Außerhalb
Des
Hauses
Bist
Oder
Das
Ist
So
Eine
Offene
Frage
Weil
Innerhalb
Vom
WLAN
Und
Da
Wo
Der
Home
Assistant
Server
Steht
Okay
Aber
Wenn
Ich
Außerhalb
Bin
Dann
Müsste
Das
Brauche
Ich
Dann
In
Ein
Home
Assistant
Cloud
Abo
Oder
Sowas
Dann
Würde
Ich
Wahrscheinlich
Auch
Darüber
Machen
Ja
Nice
, Laura
Ist
Halt
Laura
Ist
Für
Den
Normalen
Heim
Anwender
Halt
So
Ein
Richtiges
Nischen
Ding
Wie
Gesagt
Laura Ist
Cool
Ich Hab's
Geschafft Von
Hier Bis
Zum Friedhof
Zu
Funken
Über
Laura
Das
Ist
Irgendwie
1,5
Bis
Kilometer
Weg
Aber
Im
Heimbereich
Ist
Das
Glaube
Ich
Ziemlich
Nische
Require
Mesh
Network
Each
New
Sensor
That
You
Add
To
Your
Hub
Shows
Up
Right
In
Amazon
Echo
Ready
To
Be
Used
As
A
Trigger
For
A
Routine
So
Automating
Is
Just
About
As
Simple
It
Could
Be
But
At
The
Moment
All
There
Integrations
Are
Minute
Video
On
These
Contact
Sensors
Highlighting
The
Pros
And
Cons
Of
Each
One
But
Honestly
There
Is
Just
No
Reason
The
Car
Sensor
Is
Better
Than
The
Rest
By
A
Significant
Margin
Nice
Hab ich
Alles
Richtige
Gekauft
Das
Video
Ist
Das
Nicht
Schon
Overkill
Es
Ist
Immer
Die
Frage
Was
Du
Machen
Willst
Wenn
Die
Andere
Nicht Funktionieren
Und Das
Das Einzige
Ist Was Geht
Ist Es Kein Overkill
Ist Das Beste
Für
Dich
Auch
Ne
Ich
Beide
Nichts
Vom
Video
Weil
Ich
Habe
Den
Kram
Ja
Schon
Exzellent
Ja
Das
Richtig
Park
Das
Projekt
Ich
Habe
Hunger
Leute
Wie
Lang
Bin
Ich
Schon
An
Stunden
Die
Heute
In
Die
Zeit
Aber
Schnell
Rum
Ja
Wah Wahnsinn
Ich
Gar Nicht
Gedacht
Pippo
Fett
Hat
Ja
Es
Werden
Mehr
Geräte
Unterstützt
Und
Ich
Persönlich
Kann
Man
Sich
Jetzt
Drüber
Streiten
Ich
Persönlich
Finde
Das
Web
Interface
Mit
Der
Home
Assistant
Integration
Besser
Also
Zigbee
Selbst
To
Home
Assistant
Na
Super
Gibt
Irgendwelche
Mal
Gucken
Blablablablablablablablabla
Ja
Das
Ist
Web
Interface
Was
Man
Da
Bekommt
Finde
Ich
Persönlich
Relativ
Angenehm
Du
Hast
Nämlich
Zugriff
Komplett
Auf
Alles
Kannst
Dir
Alles
Im
Detail
Angucken
Und
Die
Unterstützten
Mehr
Geräte
Und
Oftmals
Bei
Diesen
Geräten
Auch
Mehrere
Äh
Wie
Heißt
Das
Bei
Zigbee
Device
Modes
Oder
Sowas
Also
Bei
Zigbee
Weiß
Nicht
Wie
Es
Heißt
Aber
Bei
Z-Wave
Hast
Du
Ja
Verschiedene
Sachen
Äh
So
Ein
Gerät
Hat
Er
Verschiedene
Nodes
Intern
Ja
Du
Hast
Dann
Sowas
Wie
Sensor
Open
Close
Batteriestand
Batterie
Low
Äh
Temperatur
Temper
Sensor
Was
Auch
Immer
Das
Musst
Du
Alles
Unterstützen
Dass
Du
Es
Eben
Komplett
Einbinden
Kannst
Ja
Also
Ich
Mag
Das
Ich
Find
Zigbee
To
MQT
Ist
Äh
Dieses
Ding
Gibt's
Da
Noch
Das
Ist
Von
Denen
Die
Den
Konbi
Stick
Herstellen
Das
Ist
Auch
Ein
Web
Interface
Äh
Das
Ist
Aber
Hauptsächlich
Gut
Für
Lichter
Ja
Das
Ist
Hauptsächlich
Gut
Wenn
Du
Lichter
Und
Sowas
Machen
Willst
Ähm
Die
Unterstützen
Weniger
Geräte
Als
Zigbee
To
MQTT
Ja
Man
Muss
Immer
Das
Ist
Halt
Die
Sache
Wenn
Man
Es
Selbst
Macht
Man
Muss
Sich
Ein
Bisschen
Schlau
Machen
Was
Denn
Für
Seinen
Anwendungszweck
Die
Beste
Lösung
Ist
Nee
Du
Dankeschön
Für
Den
Sub
Jetzt
Wo
Ich
Das
Sehe
Euch
Schon
Gezeigt
Hab
Ich
Euch
Schon
Gezeigt
Ich
Hab
Euch
Schon
Gezeigt
Dass
Ich
Letztens
Auf
YouTube
Ein
Web
Comic
Gekuckt
Hab
Der
Sich
Internet
Explorer
Chan
Nande
YouTube
What
The
Fuck
Was
Es
Nicht
Alles
Gibt
Internet
Explorer
Chan
Oh
Man
Es
Ist
Mittlerweile
Alles
Verweept
Okay
Wo
Wir
Dabei
Sind
Ein
Video
Gucken
Wir
Noch
What
Is
Nam
History
Of
Twitch
Anti
Weep
Emote
Any
Numbers
Every
Emote
Has
A
Story
Some
Darker
Than
Others
Behind
All
These
Emotes
Is
A
Face
Personality
A
History
Das
Ist
Die
Modern
Warfare
Menü
Musik
Im
Hintergrund
Why
It
Became
So
Popular
My
Goal
Is
To
Hunt
Down
And
Talk
To
As
Many
Of
These
Emotes
As
I
Possibly
Can
If
You
Have
Any
Knowledge
About
Twitch
Emotes
There
Are
Three
Main
Extensions
For
Users
To
Download
The
Most
Popular
Being
Better
TTV
Just
Like
Twitch
Has
Their
Own
Global
Emotes
Better
TTV
Has
Their
Own
As
Well
This
Intrigued
This
Emote
Is
Immensely
Popular
Within
The
Twitch
Community
But
It's
A
B
T
V
Global
Emote
Of
Course
I'm
Talking
About
The
Emote
For
This
Episode
Nam
The
Third
Most
Popular
Emote
Being
Used
1.9
Billion
Times
Nam
Was
Uploaded
Global
Emote
On
December
12th
It
Makes
You
Wonder
What's
The
Story
Behind
This
Twitch
Emote
What
The
Hell
Is
Nam
Alter
Macht's
Doch
Nicht
Immer
So
Laut
Mensch
Alter
Twitch
Emote
Memes
Sind
Schon
Teilweise
Echt
Hängen
Geblieben
So
I
Know
Where
Again
I
Think
Was
Still
In
College
I
Don't
Remember
What
I
Was
Playing I
Don't
Know
That
Face
If
I
Had
To
Guess
It
Was
Probably
A
Moment
Where
Maybe
I
Don't
Know
If
It
Was
During
A
Game
What
Not
And
Then
I
Had
Like
A
Puzzle
Reaction
So
I
Just
Kind
Of
Made
Like
A
Weird
Face
I
Guess
And
I
Guess
That
Moment
Somebody
Took
A
Picture
Of
It
And
Then
It
Just
That
Was
The
Name
Emote
I
Mean
Being The
Face
Of
One
Was
Jetzt
Like
My
Face
Is
Like
Pretty
Popular
Or
He
Showed
Me
Like
A
Guy
Named
Nim
You
Know
So
He
Had
Like
A
Whole
Big
Old
Nam
Community
I
Think
It
Definitely
Blew
Up
There
I
Mean
Before
That
You
Know
I
Think
The
Reason
Why
People
Span
My
Face
Back
In
The
Day
Because
It
Was
Like
One
Of
The
Biggest
Emotes
Right
In
Nim's
Community
I
Guess
You
Know
People
Like
Spam
Nam
You
Know
I
Think
That's
Pretty
Cool
Just
Like
Kind
Of
Like
That
Warm
Feeling
You
Know
Nam
Has
Always
Had
The
Same
Meaning
For
Years
And
Weebs
Get
The
Fuck
Out
A
Direct
Counter
To
Those
Who
Spam
A
Yaya
These
Two
Emotes
Are
The
Easiest
Way
To
Start
A
Chat
War
One
Mention
Of
Either
And
It's
Already
Too
Late
That
Chat
Room
Will
Be
Non-Stop
Nam
Vers
A
Yaya
Spam
For
At
Least
Minutes
This
Clip
By
Pilata
Most
Definitely
Helped
Boost
The
Popularity
Of
The
E-Mode
Okay
Why
The
Fuck
Do
You
Have
A
Weeb
What's
Going
On
Now
What
The
Hell
Is
That
C++
What
Is
That
C++
And
Then
I
Don't
Wondert
Me
Now
Nothing
More
Now
Was
Ist
Da
Überhaupt
Los
Gerade
Das
Ist
Für
Alle
Hyperaktiven
C++
Programmierer
Oder
Was
Weebs
Out
Spread
Around
Twitch
Like
Wildfire
Everyone
And
Their
Mother
Was
Saying
It
Two
Songs
Will
Also
Be
Created
About
E-Mode
DJ
Fortnite
Gamer
Twitches
Bubus
Damn
Nam
Spam
Ich
Kann
Das
Gar
Nicht
Lauter
Machen
Weil
Die
Schreien
Zeiten
Woran
Auf
Twitch
Ich finde es faszinierend, dass ein Emote wie NAMM so erfolgreich ist, sieben Jahre lang und es gibt kein Zeichen, dass es aufhört.
Echt die Definition eines klassischen Twitch-Emotes. Es hat seinen Spot gefunden und es gibt nichts, was die Energie und die Gesichter von NAMM verändern kann.
Es ist schon lange her, dass ich ein Emote habe und ich weiß, dass es immer noch genutzt wird.
Ich denke, ich gehe zurück, es ist ein bisschen schmerzhaft. Es ist ziemlich cool, dass es immer noch genutzt wird, dass es immer noch genutzt wird.
Und es ist cool, dass es immer noch genutzt wird. Für mich ist es lustig, dass es genutzt wird.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Natürlich musste ich die wichtigste Frage von allen fragen.
Ist es in oder aus?
Ist das eine Rhetorik-Frage?
Weaves out, Bro. Geh doch mal raus.
Oh, Mann.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
NAMMers.
So.
Jetzt haben wir uns wieder weitergebildet, was Twitch Chat ähm...
ähm...
History angeht.
HyperGachi.
Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich wollte nämlich heute eigentlich noch ein Video aufnehmen,
falls ich das nicht schon erwähnt habe.
Was gibt's? Äh...
Lass mal überlegen. Was gibt's zu essen?
Äh...
Ich glaube noch Überbleibsel
von gestern.
Was heißen würde Lachs und Nudeln?
Und äh... China-Chinesen,
Süß-Sauersauce.
Namm. Namm-Namm-Namm. Ja.
Ah, ja.
So. Gibt's...
irgendjemand, den wir hosten können?
Ist mein Manager
wieder on und spielt Valorant? Müssen wir mal gucken.
Wenn ja, dann hosten wir ihn.
Nein.
Ist er nicht.
Sieben Days Ago hier. So wird das aber mit
Streaming-Lifestyle
nix.
Ähm... Haben wir sonst irgendjemanden am Start?
Der Krieger ist on.
Red Dead Redemption juckt mich aber überhaupt gar nicht.
Ähm...
Highscore Heroes Valorant in dem Fall
juckt mich auch nicht.
Ist da sonst noch irgendjemand
Kleines, der es verdient hat, dem ich folge?
Zeig mal her.
Nö.
Hm... Da fällt mir jetzt nix ein.
Das hier ist doch garantiert...
Chat, erklärt mir mal.
Ich spreche es nicht aus.
Das ist doch garantiert so eine typische Twitch-Chat
Fangfrage, oder?
Dass, wenn man das ausspricht,
dann...
sagt man was anderes, was
eigentlich da steht.
Das ist doch so ein typischer Twitch-Chat
Cheatbait. Ist es nicht?
Es gibt
wirklich Streamer, der angelt.
Ihn haben wir schon oft gehostet.
Ist er am Start?
Ist wieder am Start. Was macht er denn?
Dinger.
Python-Stells. Ne, Motul.
Was ist das? Was macht er da?
Was bin ich sehend?
Open... Open S...
Keine Ahnung.
Kenny sagt mir gar nix.
Ich glaube, ich hosteut niemand.
Ich gehe einfach off.
Was ist mit dem Friseur?
Der ist ja bestimmt nicht on, oder?
Der ist ja nie on.
Drei Monate ago und irgendwelche Weep-Games.
Guckt es euch an.
Was war er? Vor drei Monaten war er on?
Und was ist hier?
Wie gesagt, weeps in.
Was hat er denn da in der Hand?
Was?
Ach, das ist der Schwanz von der Katze.
Chat, wir sehen uns.
Nächstes Mal machen wir
Broggers-Stells. Machen wir hier weiter
und versuchen das noch ein bisschen schneller zu machen.
Ich gehe jetzt
was essen. Bis denn. See you.